[Music]
we have Houdini versus stockfish who
could ask for more in the finals of the
computer Chess Championship
Bobby Hess is here with me and we are
gonna do this thing are you ready I'm
ready you're so happy today you know who
could ask for more it is Komodo Komodos
feel a little bit left that's right who
could ask for more the answer to that
question was Komodo but let's remind
everybody of what went down over the
last 72 to 96 hours in after day one you
saw the standings right as they were
before you stock fishing and Houdini and
Komodo were right there on top three but
no coincidence I guess that is that
ended up being what it was for pretty
much the rest of the event
Houdini maintained a half a point to a
full point lead over Komodo the entire
the entire tournament really and even
with the big guns going at it in the
final day of our round-robin preliminary
event Houdini
swiped one from stock fish actually
split that match with two decisive
results komodo drew both games versus
stock fish but in the end it was a half
point that somewhere somehow along the
way Robert Houdini picked up from one of
the lower engines probably gold right
let's blame gold let's blame Fizbo let's
throw those clowns under the bus just
kidding we love all the engines and the
developers and everybody that has
committed to to providing amazing
amazing analysis for an end just engines
for the world to use but again Fizbo we
waved goodbye to you as we will no
longer see that adorable face in our
broadcast so everyone say bye to Fitz
buh-bye Fizbo life is oh you know Danny
I think I as a games are just getting
underway I think I found where the
difference was okay looks like komodo
split one out of two with shredder
whereas Houdini beat shredder to zero
and of course since the two were
separated by half a point that's where
Houdini got the edge makes sense one of
the things I got to remind everybody
about is the format of our super final
we
have multiple different time controls
with these engines going at it with each
other in 15 - which is what the most of
the event was that rapid time control
after four games both both engines
getting both colors we will move to ten
- and rinse and repeat both engines will
get both colors and all four games will
go down simultaneously then we'll move
into blitz and eventually yes you will
have the world's two strongest engines
at least in this format in our first
year of the chess calm computer Chess
Championship going at it in Bullitt I
can't wait
Robert where to start there are so many
different games to start with right I
mean there are four games actually to be
exact and so where where do we want to
start we want to take a look at the
games where stockfish is white against
Houdini or the games where Houdini is
white against stockfish hey today Danny
because all games started with one d4
and we definitely did not see a lot of
d4 in the preliminary stage so
something's happened something's in the
water and stockfish is jumping out with
d4 today but if we start off with the
first game we see that it's okay only
two moves have been played in this one
but we see D Ford c4 by white d5 an e6
by black and you know that's interesting
to me because if we go to game three I
know we're hopping around a little
quickly right now I just so the games
are getting underway we see that d 4e 6e
for d5 turn into a French where white
did not take on d5 so Houdini instead of
playing the exchange variation first he
started with deep Ward jump into a
French and did not exchange so
something's going on today Danny so
you're looking at the games where I'm
sorry I'm trying to figure out how we
want to cover the super final I've got
so many different things I've been
honestly I'm a little jacked up on
coffee I've been producing this show for
about two hours
cheers Cheers to all of my caffeinated
brother brethren but what where do you
want to go I pulled up the scene with
stockfish as white we have I think I
think what we'll do is we'll focus on
all four of the games in action from
that perspective what does stockfish
doing when he's white and and what is
Houdini doing when he's white so where
would you like to start
well I mean I was looking at first where
the stock fish the first game where
stock fishes white where the third move
Knight of six was just played and I was
saying how in this game
black head and they entered into a
Queens gambit declined to a position
normal very normal
opening thus far right then I jumped
over and started to do this to you Danny
because I know you're you know
controlling everything I say we're
Houdini is white and Game three so
that's the first game where Houdini is
white okay
enter to French though they started with
d4 so at d4e six and instead of playing
c4 white chose to play efore and opted
into a French that is not in exchange
we're getting into the this line where
the main line where white has pushed for
in the center with B fives just
interesting how the two computers are
handling the one d4 differently yeah
well we are getting a French we actually
saw this advanced variation of the
French the board there directly to your
right
almost everytime shredder played white
against the French which for those who
have been following the entire event for
the last few days we thank you for your
support
you know the shredder has has played the
allele in Chatard attack and here we see
it again here Robert with the move h4 on
the board and the game to our left where
Houdini as white as you said the first
game this has become not necessarily an
Enzo right now we're in our in a Queen's
Indian really at the moment Knight f3
was played and then the commitment of g3
were in it were in a Queen's Indian and
I'm interested to see what happens here
because we saw Houdini grind down
stockfish I don't know there's any other
way to say it right we saw Houdini grind
down stock fish yesterday in a shocking
in a shocking way in in that NIMS oh
honey Queen's Indian hybrid right so
we'll see if Houdini can do it again
they're on the board to the left let's
choose a place I guess it let's let's go
back to the to the games where stock
fishes white real quick and check on
those before we decide to commit to a
game and maybe focus on the analysis so
I mean Russ and Danny yeah it was
interesting so stock was just two whites
and Houdini is two ways yeah how are
they make different openings in their
games right like they have this engine
running because the same you know is the
same engine so how do they have should
have it have they chosen different
openings I get
the two first moves are equivalent value
and they're just swapping between men I
don't I mean that's an interesting
question for our our our assistants here
maybe norm and Pete the guys behind the
iron curtains can that can help us
answer that I mean is it is it a I mean
we know that the format of the event to
remind everybody of what that is is well
that's the format of how the pairings
were done but the details of the actual
games and how the engines were prepared
for our particular format you know we
asked the the engine developers to
remove all opening books program in a
decent level of contempt so we don't
have drawers or resignations and allow
table basis to stay on so if we get a
theoretically one or drawn ending
believe us the engines will
theoretically win or draw that end game
but I don't know whether they also gave
them sort of a variety of choices to go
with right I don't know what the answer
is to that if if it's just a matter of
personality maybe Houdini
maybe Houdini likes to play the field
what do you want me to say I don't know
I mean maybe he just likes to bounce
around yeah I really think it's just you
know they're approximately equal
evaluations for the moves so essentially
it's any random you know randomness
ensues when there are equal values for
moves and thus that that's why we see
these different openings but about the
openings themselves you know we want to
talk about the you know the games in
action the match go ahead I said the
match whereas stockfish is white in this
first game cuz thought there's two
whites we see that white is much more
space looks very comfortable here I
don't love black set up with both a6 and
c6 I know it of course that's common in
many structures but feels like at the
moment it's been a bit of wasted time so
I think that white has actually jumped
out to a leading the Bell so also h6 is
kind of a weird move to have thrown in
here because the bishop on f4 looks
totally happy to grab the d6 square and
prevent the black counterpart from from
challenging in there so I guess the
question is what will black have a
knight h5 at some point Robert to try to
pick up the bishop here here or what are
your thoughts on that well I'm always
hesitant to play with a knight h5
especially with the pawns on h6 because
I have tonight h5 Bishop e5 you're
certainly not going f6 there because
then a g6 square is White's for the
taking
so after a nice ride Bishop e5 and you
don't really want to capture on e5 whoa
Jeep as soon as I was talking I say g5
yeah that called me off god I hate that
move you know why can just retreat the
bishop g3 and now you know can unite h5
with the same idea of getting the two
bishops but you've really compromised
your king sized squares and I think that
this favour is white immensely I think
you can just Castle queenside and allow
black to take the bishop on g3 take with
the H pawn and use the open H file to
your advantage
yeah I mean the bishop pair is the
bishop pair last time we checked right
it that is still a thing and so
certainly getting the dark square bishop
early is something and the engines all
love the bishop pair that's that's one
of their things they all tend to agree
on but I agree with you that if this
type of structure happens I really like
White's chances here because it feels
like the black King isn't going to have
a happy happy destination on either side
of the board the Queen side or the king
side because of all the ponds that have
been moved so well we'll see okay so
stock fish has played the move we kind
of predicted their castles long together
so as white in this first game I guess
we're kind of preferring stock fishes
chances what about the second game we're
stock fishes white let's check out that
game with a this one seems to have
transposed into sort of a closed cattle
land right this is kind of a neo close
cattle in yeah it has except the bishop
is on c3 and Knight undie too so I guess
you know what it is no bishop before
check line the bishop went to d2 black
for treated the Bishop from b4 to e7
earlier on and then white opted to go
Bishop c3 Knight to g2 so yeah you're
exactly right it is kind of a close
cattle that's now opening up after this
move c5 I think Black has done well to
equalize here I really don't see Inge
for white White's pieces are awkwardly
placed quite frankly is Bishop c3
actually agree I think complete equality
and this is a type of position that
Houdini needs I feel like they're the
closed structure as we saw yesterday
when Houdini was white when actually
defeated stockfish it plays well in
these closed structures which is why I
don't like its position in the first
game with the more open structure but
we'll see how that one turns out for now
one instructor thing will keep our
on everybody and try to offer whatever
edumacation we can is likely we're gonna
get a hanging pawn structure okay so the
night pops into e5 here staying with
this first game real quick before we
move to where Houdini is white the the
night coming to e5 opens up the bishop
on g2 obviously but the main thing is
the tension here between these pawns
that's what you got to keep an eye on
because black typically doesn't want to
take and leave himself with this
isolated isolated d5 pawn but if the
tension builds up to the point where
something has to give
right then likely you're gonna see white
capturing on c5 and so we'll have a
position of a hanging pawn structure
which should provide some interesting
instructive stuff because those are very
dynamic positions so all right let's
move on to the next game where Houdini
is white the first affair being what is
a big center yet again for Houdini and
again this is reminding me of the game
yesterday from Dame 3 where Houdini I
know it's not exactly the same obviously
it's not it's not an Enzo same as
structure it's not doubled see pawns of
course for white but the big center and
and and that what happened in that space
advantage where Houdini kind of played
shuffle puck with the rooks but then
broke through and had what you and I
both agreed was kind of the win of the
whole tournament right yeah that was a
beautiful game and it sort of does
remind me of that because of the big
center however there's too much tension
in this position to be too similar to
yesterday's game that said of course
white is better here white has more
space just look at the pawns right twice
three pawns on the fourth rank where
black only has one on its own fourth
rank up on c5 and if black ever releases
in tension with C takes d4 white will be
staring down barreling down on that pawn
on d6 and so that's a difficult pawn to
protect in some variations that said you
know whites you start with rook d2 and
rook a d1 but of course black and then
you'll rub e to d8 and just defend
everything on the D file as well so I
think that the position is slightly
better for white but you saw the lots of
proof okay so moving on to the final and
fourth game that is going on again let
me remind you everybody what's happening
in this super final they are playing all
five of the time controls you see there
above our analysis board we will keep of
course a running scoreboard for you but
they're playing all four games at once
okay these these guys don't need to rest
in between games because they're not
guys they're computer chips
all four games are going once really
we're the ones you're gonna need a break
after this whole thing so okay Wow
I really just live with board for the
first time this looks like it's it's
quickly becoming one of the most
imbalance games of all this this last
game where Houdini is white robber we
have Kings on opposite sides of the
board you know how that gets me going
you know don't get me started there that
makes me feel good and and we this rook
came to g1 the cannon getting behind the
pawn don't don't let it fool you here
that rook has nasty intentions along the
G file so so I don't know it could just
be my bias for them for my love of going
for an unsound checkmate attack but I
like the chances of this game becoming a
really fun one yeah absolutely and I
think that white is better here
you know I don't have an evaluation
about what what leads me to think that
white is better is that wise King is
very safe at least for the time being
blacks King is also safe for now but the
structure without an F pawn that's what
we call the golden pond is usually a
great pond of protecting the King so if
this Knight is pushed back from g4 and
then Y can go G for itself and push
forward on the Kings side and launch an
attack of course that goes in White's
favor another important factor is this
pawn on e6 is what we call backward pawn
yes it does defend d5 but is vulnerable
to attack and cannot be protected by
another pawn so whereas white has
technically a backward part on g3 that
pawn is never gonna be under attack this
is very hard to get there this pawn to
e6 can you compile pressure on it and
then just keep that tension and ask
black what you're gonna what's gonna do
to keep the position static and not just
end up in a much worse position so it's
a great point I think because of that
idea of the e6 pawn the main two
candidate moves for white might be one
you can consider capturing the knight on
c6 in these positions if it allows you
to fully focus and dominate the dark
square by removing that pony and indeed
as I say that Houdini has gone for that
I was gonna say the risk of taking there
is that black maybe takes with the be
pawn and you might see that B file
become an asset for stockfish in a queen
side attack the other move that was
being considered for white or at least
in my mind would be to bring the bishop
all the way back to f1 not even to d3 or
e2 with the idea of relocating itself
Robert to this h3 e6 diagonal kind of a
spy against that weak pawn so I think
both those moves would have kept a small
edge for white
all right but as we say look at us we
are we are I feel like you and I are
predicting more of the engines moves the
more we do this am I crazy if I just
lost my mind no we're getting better
here in the predicting another move
queen d4 initially I wasn't saying
Knight to e4
yeah idea behind before was to go Knight
f2 and trade off the night because the
e5 square is White's night for the
taking but before C was kind of like an
Queen d4 there with the I beat idea
being that c5 was not possible because
then 94 is extremely power I like your
first suggestion honestly and so did
Houdini because to me that tempo and the
end the release of the knight on g4 is
really I mean that's what the cohesive
follow-up would be to Bishop takes c6
right the drawback of Bishop takes c6
will be the B file at some point but if
you can get rid of that Knight as you
said I really like that plan watch for
this dark square to become you know like
I said jay-z has some rap songs about
about weaknesses on those kind of dark
squares so I mean beyond things lemonade
something I don't know well this is
exactly was to say I didn't like
allowing a 5 because there's game deck
well once you capture on g4 there's
gonna be a pin on that night and yes
you've been sacrificed to exchange it
for Knight takes g4 Bishop takes g4
Knight takes e5 Bishop d1 take back on
d1 let's say and then but you know
Komodo would go for this in a heartbeat
I love this look at that nighttime 5
practically speaking it's great for
white because then 95 is an awesome
piece but that's why I wanted to go
Queen d4 first you prevent black from
playing a5 and threatened 94 nonetheless
and then they can go to c5 if you want
not just f2 and so I thought that was a
better path for and rook f1 talked about
a move you do not expect to be play you
know you're you and you may end up being
right honestly the I mean it's hard to
evaluate because that's a rook f2 you do
definitely want to take on f4 to open
the g file and if you eat for that night
just goes into e5 and it's not being
kicked out and black may be the one
sacrificing exchange an e5 at some point
yeah yeah rook F on was a weird move I
mean honestly my first instinct was
maybe Houdini isn't as as open to the
idea of an exchange sac right we know we
know Komodo is a try positional
chess player he's a he's a cheese a try
positional whereas Houdini is a little
more static right likes his like his
likes his positions he'd knows well but
fried positional kind of like the
Triwizard Tournament Harry Potter yeah
well yeah you know I'm I'm a try Jesse
well I've tried a lot of chess in my
life so let's let's go back to stock
fishes games as white we'll go back to
Game one with both sides having their
kings on the Queen side but stock fish
maintaining and enjoying a nice little
space advantage there on the other Kings
side Plus this H pawn did become weak
and the way we sort of predicted that it
might but okay black has the bishop pair
and that G v square is open so with rook
h3 being a nice move that both
prophylactically guards III and prepares
to double again I feel like we're doing
a good job of predicting these natural
moves here but I feel like this is
pretty unbalanced I think Komodo has
gotten some compensation for the week H
file I mean sorry not Komodo Houdini
yeah absolutely and the reason why is
that a bishops best friend when a pawn
is next to it is that the fact there's
no pawn on the spot and this can sound
very complicated but essentially my
points that there's no H font for white
yep so that means bishop on g5 is safe
there forever because there's a pot on
h6 defending it and is upon f5 of course
that can't go backwards to go to f4 an
attack at bishop the bishop is nicely at
home on g5 that said the e3 pawn is not
really that much of a target it's not
easy to get there at some point why he's
going like efore just blast open the
position and after rook h e8 was indeed
played you really can start considering
moves like 'if or at some point you
might want to go Knight B 3 into c5
that's a huge square to infiltrate at me
like that
I think black is okay though I mean I
really do I agree I feel like I yeah
with e4 obviously the the advantages of
e4 to be aggressive and obviously if he
can force the trade on e4 stockfish is
going to be aggressively bringing a
knight into that c5 square but the
structural change will be leaving white
with this newly-created iqp on d4 right
and that's why Houdini gobbles it up the
question will be is stockfish is brute
force approach here Robert where he's
just gonna open the center and drop then
I don't see five and be aggressive with
an attack we see he's already taken back
is that gonna make up for his
you know his positional you know
looseness there right not worrying about
the deep on it
something tells me stock fish is really
good at these types of attacks and and
the timely positional sacrifice whether
it's actually going to amount to a pawn
sacrifice or just the weakness on d4 so
I don't know this will be this will be
an interesting one to watch now as the C
file becomes a main point of focus yeah
I'm just not sure how they're enough
pieces left it sounds weird to say but
I'm just not sure if they're enough
pieces left for white to really seize a
huge advantage because at some point
white is probably gonna take his Bishop
on g5 because that's a great piece it's
stopping a rook from going to c1 because
the bishop start paying the night there
and if you do ever take on g5 well
you're liquidating and the pawn on d4 is
bugging me for sure so at some point
Knight takes d5 Knight b3 okay when I b3
first that makes sense but I'm telling
you that night he's gonna take that
Bishop on g5 I'm just not sure they're
quite enough pieces left for white to
really make tremendous amount of
progress all right well I'll be a little
a little predictive that if the bishop
on g5 Falls maybe we find this rook on
h6 poking at c6 maybe this pony pops
into a5 and and white does end up having
a party over there on the Queen side but
we'll come back to this and let's move
on to the game with stockfish having the
white pieces and a structure that we did
predict is now on the board with the
hanging pawns Robert let's give some
general chess advice just about what
both strategies are here when you're
playing with the hanging pawns and
against it because I think it's good
positional chess and while you're while
you're giving some instructive analysis
we'll we'll go ahead and move over to a
bigger analysis board so people can
focus on guess what we have we have our
first I just played a jingle and the
jingle was I'll play it again
[Music]
I can't hear the joy so excited about
Lea and Ely dma you made this jingle
huge shout out to you obviously diamond
Membership somebody get that man a
diamond membership well he might already
have one I don't know he's obviously a
big fan of you Bobby has to go out of
his way to make a very professional
sounding jingle so let's get a teaching
mode from Bobby has about these hanging
pawns well the problem with hanging
pawns in general is that you know quite
obviously they cannot defend each other
and the only way to do to actually
defend each other's to push one of them
but by pushing one let's say pawn to c4
black you know black can make that move
at some point but the issue with that is
always leaving the d4 square permanently
for whites taking the night will situate
self on d4 and look at that Bishop on b7
for example if one of those pawns were
to move it generally wants to be that
deep pawn in this position because it
opens up that bishop of course look at
the black rooks therein not harmonious
at all they're in very weird positions
and we just saw white give up the dark
square bishop and the reason it did that
was that if you look at the position the
knight can now go to be 2 over 2 D 3
eventually it can even consider going to
F 4 because black might have
overextended on the Kings side as a h5
pawn you're not gonna make an attack
with just one pawn and upon on d5 again
quickly becomes targeted as well so nice
e3 was indeed played instead of this
Knight B to the d3 idea but you could
still do the same exact thing right now
you're already targeting the d5 pawn
it's actually quite difficult to defend
it because if you ever go over up to d6
then I'm going after your c5 pawn so
White's idea is to go after both pawns
black is really trying to get
compensation by a some sort of pawns arm
on the King side but objectively I
really think that White's chance of
winning this game are quite high I love
it and and agreed and you know so we
talked about White's goals there and you
highlighted the bishop capturing a
knight on e5 and note everybody
stockfish is willingness to part with
the bishop pair because of what Robert
focused on which is that one also I'll
add that when you eliminate minor pieces
typically it makes both isolated and
hanging pawns weaker is that that's fair
to say right Robert so you're looking at
opportunities to make trades because
when there's a lot of minor pieces on
the board the person with the pawns has
the one advantage they have is they have
more
too often these really critical central
squares so if you're playing against the
hanging pawns and your opponent has
knights and bishops kind of hopping in
and out of all that stuff
that's where the space advantage becomes
realized but as pieces come off the
board that and now we see this really
nice very typical and thematic shot
against one of the hanging pawns that's
when the hanging plants really get
targeted and if I'm right Bobby the the
move before is gonna force c4 you up and
the whole point is that that Square you
highlighted that will become weak in a
scenario like that the d4 square and
maybe the c5 square now are gonna become
available for white yeah I mean this d4
square now like I says whites for the
taking and that's a sum I should have
mentioned when I was talking about the
deep works for that it's very thematic
for white to push b3 to b4 to provoke
that pawn forward and now look at this
d4 square how is black ever gonna attack
it you need to get your knight over
there to attack it you keep g6 Bishop g7
things like that are a long story for
now okay I was about to say this is an
important moment for black because
either you take on g3 and just exchange
pawns in which case whites King side
will never be disturbed or you place h3
move and actually h3 pawn is more of a
liability than an asset yes it kicks the
bishop and makes it not force it to make
a choice
do you go to h1 and continue putting
pressure on d5 or more likely you go to
f1 and then try to gobble up that pawn
h3 it's not an easy pawn to defend the
rook can swing over to h4 at some point
but that said if you go to f1 you have
to be careful of moving the rook on d4
because then black will consider going D
for itself and opening up that bishop
for the long diagonal because an attack
may ensue well does commit to your idea
of Istra phone which I also agree seem
to makes the most sense it also ties
down the Queen to guarding that pawn so
even if you don't follow through
aggressively with rook h4 in a position
like this everybody at home one of the
ways you can think about how you want
your pieces is that you know it keeps
your opponent sort of in an awkward
position right that's a commitment the
Queen and pawn are in a committed
relationship right so let's move on to
the next game where who the first one
where Houdini was white all four of
these games are rolling on we've gotten
a truly a truly Hedgehog position right
this is this is transposed officially
into a hedgehog structure and well one
of the things that I always wonder about
these position
it's just how dangerous is whites attack
how dangerous is things like g4 and g5 +
f5 coming without minor pieces on the
kingside I feel like I should be worried
about this but every time white advances
pollens around their own King they're
just creating more of a double edged
opportunity for black to flip the script
at some point so what is some general
teaching moments you can Alfre here
about this type of Hedgehog I think the
most important thing to keep in mind is
look for the pawn breaks I didn't say
play the pawn breaks but look for them
well that tends to want to play a move
like d5 however in this particular
position defy will always be a bad pawn
break because y can capture with the C
pawn that forces a black stay with the e
pawn and white goes 'if I've and the
four-on-three majority and the King side
will allow white to unleash a vicious
attack now Y can achieve me black can
also consider a five but e five is also
not so good because when the night comes
to f5 you're not actually gonna capture
on f4 because then that opens the G file
and not to mention that if Y is able to
capture this Bishop on f6 there are
moves an important defender on the King
side as well so what both sides are
doing now they're maneuvering they're
trying to find the right time to do a
break white can consider playing a move
like f5 itself English consider going g4
g5 that's what I would be thinking about
the right moment for that of course your
can't cannot be on h2 when you can go G
Forks that opens your King up to
discoveries with the Queen a c7 in many
lines but it's all about timing here and
this is the type of position that I see
Houdini winning just like yesterday it's
very tense neither side can make clear
progress but at the right moment I feel
like Houdini will make that progress and
actually defeat stockfish mhm
I agree again so even though we've been
talking about the similarities despite
the fact that the structure of this
position is very different than the NIM
so everybody it's it's the it's the
space advantage Robert and I are looking
at and it's just knowing what we saw
yesterday that watch what happens over
the next few moves we're gonna see some
shuffle puck we're gonna see these
pieces moving around very computer is
chess we're both recognized whites a
little better white has a space
advantage black and white both know it
but neither side wants to make the break
if they don't have to because they
generally evaluate computers really love
space and one of the things that I
remember from the man versus machine
match where we had Hikaru Nakamura pair
up with Rybka and taking on stockfish
Robert was that that that game
that he caught a kind of cat and mouse
that hikaru was able to play with stock
fish and part of the reason he had so he
had a draw and he had some games that I
thought were gonna be close to draws was
he was taking advantage of the computers
in their overvaluing of space right once
they get a space advantage they don't
like to change it they just want to sit
tight right and the one thing they got
Houdini to change the space advantage
yesterday was the contempt factor that
we've built into this match where
they're not allowed to take draws we
want them to be aggressive and and so
eventually a break was made now as I say
all that stock fish clearly recognized
something in the position that b5 which
is a very typical black Counter Strike
you talk about pawn breaks but normally
it's it's very risky to do so if you're
just gonna be hanging the pawn after
takes and Knight takes b5 but I guess
what's the issue here what's what's
going on switch games to the game where
stock fish was white is white against
Houdini because both Kings are under
heavy fire right now and they're moving
quite quickly cuz I guess time trouble
is actually becoming an issue it's a 15
minute + 2 second increment time control
and why just made a move Queen to c5
check both Kings were very vulnerable
and now the Queen's are off the board
and we see somehow equal material but I
think black is even slightly better here
I mean I just don't know exactly what
happened it looked like you know somehow
to get to blacks King White's King
became quite weak along the way as well
so you know we'll have to take a look at
this in more detail but right now I
think the black is totally out of danger
in fact I saw we prefer blacks chances
my sin game I agree totally I mean that
broke down very quickly why is rook
takes e5 check Oh rook c3 de ok so if
rook takes c5 check everybody white is
not losing a piece it's just a draw at
this point I believe but still it's a
very fascinating way meanie looked for
awhile we talked about the pressure on
the C pawn earlier is there an exchange
falling here though why it wasn't Bishop
a5 check a move Bishop f5 with check the
King can go to B - ah that's that's
fascinating look at how many pieces are
hanging in this position with anyway ok
so that the point everybody of that
tactic was if if white takes it black
takes on c3 Intermezzo with check and
wins the rook on e1 that's what I was
seeing but yeah the King can move to B -
okay so it looks like this game
is simplifying itself out but if anybody
can win it's Houdini which is a bit of a
surprise given that stockfish had the
white pieces right and so Houdini's
proving to be the magician that it's you
know it's named after and in the other
game where starfish is white it looks
like it's the equal material at first
glance I thought white was up upon but
it's just because blacks pawns are
blockaded white is slightly better for
sure but I don't see up how to make
progress I mean the problem is that
exactly says move Knight a4 that if you
ever capture on d5 then a C pawn will
become passed and right now you have to
trade some pieces on d5 here so Bishop
takes d5 you have to take with the rook
otherwise you fall victim to Knight c3
ideas and so after rook takes d5 we see
some trades and I really am not sure how
white is gonna win this and important to
keep in mind that each pawn is the wrong
color so if for some reason white goes
on up a pawn black can try to bail
itself out by giving up trading all
pawns and sacrifice tonight for let's
say the a pawn as long as only the H
pawn is remaining because that is the
wrong color a promotion Square and it's
something that I always keep in mind
when I see an endgame and I see a bishop
I look for the rook pawn queening
squared fantastic point okay so it looks
like black here yep king of c3 but then
white might try Bishop efore and then a
rook before protects the Knights okay so
rugby one check first I guess that makes
sense to try to just get that that pawn
home if c3 will probably have to see
Bishop e4 in erm is oh right before you
take the knight yeah that's exactly
what's play here I I agree with you and
I think you made a great instructive
point that's why I paused I played your
jingle about this square h8 not being
the same color as this bishop and it is
a very important thing for for all
players to keep those kind of things in
mind but I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
disagree after that or not disagree but
say I feel like white is getting more
winning chances than maybe first thought
because with this Bishop setting up a
blockade there's no yeah I wasn't saying
this rook b2 idea is just as played is
the problem is the rook and Bishop we're
gonna be pinned on the a file right so I
can just take on a two now and threaten
c2 and just
your rook away and so even if you know
you take on a six and win the C pawn the
three on two on the king size not
winning because h4 g3 III versus g7 f7
is not a winning end game because black
can just situate itself in a way where
it stops the pawns and again that it's a
three on two that is a theoretical draw
I believe okay and even with this H
pawned not having anybody in front of it
right despite the sort of mini
two-on-one majority that we have here
with the H and G pawn versus the it's
still about winning right and look day
somehow in the first game we're stocked
which is white Komodos up to pawn that
come out of pardon me Houdini's up two
pawns rook in two versus rook so with
the black pieces oh I have no idea how
that happened but I think this is
actually a theoretical draw though right
that's what's funny and with the table
base stockfish should be able to draw
this everyone this is one of those very
rare I think it's really kind of one of
the only endings where you're up to
pawns in a rook ending but it should be
a draw due to the split if the pawns are
connected of course it's a very easy
when they help each other advance but we
maybe we'll get some instructive rook
ending technique that's a clippable
moment so let's let's let's stay on the
edge of our seat here of stock which can
teach us something I think Danny we have
to go over to the game or Houdini is
wedding in stock fishing the King and
pawn ending because Houdini now is is
not I don't let's say let's do a pawn
count you see the game talking about
yeah they're risking in two pawns and I
do not believe it is winning we just do
a simple count the problem is for white
that this is an a pawn and wrote poems
are always the hardest pawns to deal
with and King and pawn enemies because
even if you're up a pawn if the black
king is able to come back over toward
that site in enough time the CH square
is the ones very important and you know
they're moving very fast now so it's
hard to even keep the pace but you know
the so King f7 King takes f5 King g7
King G 5 King h6
King beef five King takes h5 King see
five King g5 I yeah I just kind of
played out that line just to show
everybody what you were talking about
that the King right back to the corner
exactly the makes it back to the CH
Square which is enough to hold the draw
and in this situation
and the reason why is the king of CA
boxes out the white king so even if the
King is on a six that you really need to
came to be on b7 to let the pawn roll
through it so the king I see it keeps
the King out of the B file and if it
goes the B six of course the Kings goes
to b8 and stops the Queen that way so
unfortunately for white for Houdini it's
not enough in this position just even if
you win the extra pawn it's a it's a
theoretical draw so that game is all
said and done yep and just show
everybody the full line there what we're
gonna see is is the position exactly as
Robert said where you wait and box in
the King and again eventually white is
forced to basically self stalemate with
something like this the king is trapped
in and as long as the black King is
smart enough to only stay on the c7 and
c8 square shouldering the King never go
to c6 and in positions where you might
allow they came to go to b8 and rush the
pawn but staying in front of the pawn
makes this a very very easy draw so
alright so one of these games is if we
can just call it and leave this one in
our rear view this is about to be an
easy draw what about the first one where
Houdini is white another rook ending
we're getting a lot of rook endings
between these two very evenly matched
engines here in our super final again
it's similar that probably Houdini is
the only one who can win this rook and
pawn ending but Trump but it's gonna be
a draw yeah yeah yeah I think rooks you
Roxy three and you're right that if
somehow you know as humans right if the
human was trying to play four on with
black or someone's trying to play on the
content factors at an all-time high
I believe only white can win Charlie any
baby going for that he played king g2 is
he okay
we'll see Wow rook takes a to caught me
off guard there is a force draw stock
fish stock fish with the contempt didn't
take the perpetual that's surprising yep
because now now he's white now white is
really the only one we could win so
that's a strange at that's that's that's
a strange sort of way that it's
approached purely because these engines
are programmed we don't want them
drawing at least if we can avoid it
they'll never make a decision that
really loses them the game by their
evaluation but I guess dr. fish still
feels like this is gonna be a
comfortable draw and and so he's willing
to go for this right remember that they
do have the table bases like you know
the six and probably seven piece table
bases I'm not sure exactly which ones
have but six for sure and so right now
we have seven pieces on the board but
this is a draw I mean it's okay and this
is giving away the pawn I don't know why
I did that that's weird but it was a
draw to begin with and so I guess you
know just both engines noting that are
making what look like silly moves yep on
the analysis board here everybody you
can quickly see that the first one ended
in a draw and you want to speak of weird
draws Robert look at how Houdini played
that he let black go and get the corner
pawn and just ran back and still may
have this is this is typical this is why
engines aren't aren't things you should
try to emulate in terms of endgame
technique yes they know the answer like
in the back of a math book with the
table base but they're the way they
arrive at the conclusion and the answer
to that math problem is Inc is the
opposite process by which you will ever
arrive at the same answer so don't
emulate their games let's get rid of
that first draw the second rook ending
is also a draw stockfish has also drawn
one of his games already as as white so
there's really only one game left to
talk about and it's this like we said
potentially instructive moment if we can
see stockfish draw this split pawn rook
ending where black has two pawns but
theoretically should not be able to win
this right and the reason why the
important move was just made with rook
to g7 because if black were able to go
rook g8 it permanently cuts the White
King off from getting to the F pawn so
that's why rook g7 was played to stop
rook g8 which means that now and when
the rook went to d1 in the Brooklands a7
rukh g1 is not as big of a threat
because the rook the white rook can
check from the side so from you know a
four and and and so on so yeah this is a
theoretical draw it's really not that
easy in fact I've had games where I've
won with yeah
well no yeah I want to highlight I I've
had games where I've lost this as a
trying to defend and I've seen
grandmasters lose this position right
and you may have even beaten a
grandmaster you said you wanted I'm not
sure who you beat but I I know I saw
Alexander Ivanovitch all him out I've
seen other grandmasters not be able to
hold this ending under time pressure
yeah I did be the Grandmaster in his
endgame and it's you know I've also lost
the second game it's very difficult
because all the practical elements of an
game look at the
position right now right yeah the King
isn't p3 there's an F pawn that looks
like it's about to roll down the board
but the issue is that if you ever push
this pawn too far then the white king is
so close that it's able to actually have
the king and rook are able to corral the
pawn and importantly very very
importantly the last pawn remaining
would be an H pawn and as we've noted
many times the H pawn is not a good one
and king upon endings if usually it's
good with many pawns on the boards it's
a distraction but when there's so few
left you're not gonna be able to promote
simply an H pawn so that's a great point
I'll try to give some instructive
patterns or some thought processes you
can have here because as Robert said yes
we all know it's a theoretical draw but
there's a reason grandmasters have both
won and lost this from both sides right
because it's not that easy
so knowing the answer is different than
being able to do it in practice and I'll
give a few takeaways here so one of the
key things you're seeing is that the
king is on the short side of the F pawn
what that means is that if you split the
board in half from the F pawn you would
have the e to the a file versus the G
and the H you always want your King on
the short side of that split because
that allows your rook to have the
maximum amount of distance between
yourself and the enemy King which allows
a whole bunch of checks to run wild
meaning the black King can't get to you
to stop your checks without leaving the
F pawn behind that's a critical factor
that consistently is preventing black
from just running forward with the King
in the F pawn because that rook will
check the second thing Roberts said and
I just want to say even more because if
there's sometimes the way humans have to
draw these Robert right is not by doing
what stock fish or Houdini are doing
knowing a table base or calculating to
depth 30 they have to know the patterns
and the goals that they're aiming for
because that's the way we can
conceptualize our our drawing method and
so King on short slide rook on long side
that's a tip you need to never forget
King on short side rook on long side the
second tip you want to never forget is
what Robert said about abandoning the H
pawn you actually if you're ever in a
position where okay now it happened
finally because they had to play for for
a win but eventually very often if black
had taken a different approach and run
the F pawn you would have seen white not
take the H pawn and just run back in
front of the upon if that pawn crosses
the line the H pawn is the one you leave
behind holy crap that just rhymed
if the F
on crosses the line the H pawn is the
one you leave behind that's why I come
up with rhymes makes it easier for me to
remember complicated stuff so this one's
gonna be a draw Robert in the opposite
way because black eventually just gave
this silly check and gave the H pawn but
what you were saying right was that if
the black King got fully committed with
the F pawn you would use your rook on
long side King on short side to
eventually leave the H pawn go Corral
the F pawn again leave the H pump behind
that's how you're gonna draw these
endings so sorry to go on and on about
that but I really want to I think this
is a really cool moment if we can
provide some instruction because
stockfish is gonna make this draw look
easy but we all know it's not it's not
so simple no that was actually a really
great way to frame that because it is a
very difficult endgame as we both noted
we've seen grandmasters win and lose
this endgame and so those talking points
are actually crucial the critical if
you're gonna play and get a position
like this you need to know them in order
to defend and we of course these engines
have table bases and there's a draw I
don't want to say without difficulty
because for us for human comprehension
it is very difficult but a lot of things
you said and make perfect sense just
having the King on the short side and
then the rook checking from the long
side is very very important to not just
this endgame but many others as well and
of course we have a whole lot of
probably more videos about rook endings
than almost anything anything else in
our premium video library so there's my
shameless plug to upgrade today
seriously it's we've got several great
video series by your molinsky by Mel
Akashi and I also did a reckoning series
so they are very important once to
master because when you're tend to be
equally matched with someone like stock
fish and Houdini what did we just have
Robert we had four Brook endings just
now right didn't we and it was or at
least three out of four and that happens
so Brook endings both from a technical
just you need to know the ideas and the
positions you hear terms like Philidor
latina right lasker you hear these
different types of defensive names where
I just kind of I have image association
with that name but then also having
experience in Brook endings can never be
underestimated so alright partner well
let's let's take a breath here because
guess what we have we have round one in
the books the matches tied two points
apiece your thoughts on what we've seen
after the four games of the 15 to
portion finished those are some
fascinating battles I really thought
we're gonna see some decisive games and
I'm not disappointed
all by four drawers I mean that matches
two to two it really could have gone
either way and I just want to give a
shout out in the twitch chat to número
it who said that's the difference
between Danny and Robert Robert says I
won this position and Danny says I lost
this position so that was a really funny
jab at you Danny well and thanks for
going out of your way to say it that was
thanks for doing that that really that
seemed really relevant at the time on my
eyes so I had to but you know trying to
be relevant and stay on task here is I
really thought that both engines were in
their element I think that Houdini
especially the game with there's a
hedgehog structure it kind of had this
long term advantage where both sides are
shuffling and that's exactly how we saw
it win the game yesterday overstock fish
on the other hand we saw stock fish in
that initial game with Hawaii is a
pretty open position I thought that by
kind of brute computing force that stock
fish would overpower Houdini and win but
we did see as I kind of was hinting at a
lot of trades occurred and there weren't
enough pieces left on the board for
whites again advantage and of course the
and a weird thing where they give up all
their their pawns don't make a draw but
did it what about you what did you think
about that opening round uh you know it
was a little fast and furious I guess I
feel like reflection may be needed right
I'll take this one and with me to
therapy next week but the I think what
was interesting is I felt like there
were several critical moments like I'll
highlight one here on the on the board
in the middle game where my point is
that they both made the right decisions
they made the mature decisions and
eventually it's simplified into an equal
game but with less time on the clock how
are they gonna handle like said position
in front of us here like a complicated
middle game with hanging pawn structures
and both sides having a different
dynamic approach that's needed in order
to get an edge in the position so I
think my biggest takeaway Robert is how
excited I am for the next few rounds
because as less time is on the clock
here I just can't wait to see the
blunders right I'm sitting here waiting
we know I blunder for a living I'm loved
it when I'm joined right misery loves
company and and and that's what I'm
hoping for so I I can't wait for the
next round
I'm sitting here waiting and it has
begun yeah yeah yeah all right let's
start with we have stock fish the white
pieces against Houdini a d4 then we have
Houdini with the white pieces we have a
French back to stock fish with the white
pieces another d4 stock fish likes
himself a d4 him himself itself whatever
and then we have Houdini with me for so
this is interesting with shorter time
controls I think we're really gonna have
a split Robert in terms of the different
approaches that each engine is taking
with white yeah and and just remind the
viewers this the time control for the
first round that we just saw was
15-minute plus two second increment per
move now we're at ten minutes plus two
second increment per move and that's
like a huge difference those five
minutes are gonna be eaten up quickly
and so with the shorter time so as you
said Danny when those tense positions
those kind of hang upon type positions
come to be with less time in the clock
it will be difficult so ya think as you
were saying about this kind of french vs
d 4 versus e 4 a mindset but it's it's
kind of been working out for both in the
engines I mean they've been getting the
positions that they seem to want with
each color
yeah I agree and the the main game I I
want to go to actually since we have our
choice so let's let's start with the the
first game where Houdini is white
because we have our first I think really
truly traditional advanced French this
is this is a variation of the French
that you get this structure a lot in the
French everybody which is very typical
you get the pawn Chainz white focus on
the kingside black focused on the
queenside and all the all the dynamics
that happen around d4 and Robert and I
have really spent the last three days
talking a lot about this pawn structure
so if you this is your first chest calm
computer first championship show back up
and watch the replays but Robert but but
the actual advanced itself is not a
theoretically very popular line anymore
right and I think it's a very
straightforward way for black to play
here comes Queen to b6 and usually I
think this line works out well for black
at least on a theoretical level but what
can you what can you tell the fans about
how white now has to deal with the
obvious threat that black is going to go
gobble the d4 pawn well oftentimes
actually white sacrifices that pawn so
the castle and if C takes D
or everything takes and castle was
indeed played there's always capture
zone before after the Queen comes to d4
white goes Knight f3 and the key is that
white gets insanely fast development yes
down this deep on but the really fast
development the night on d7 is not
exactly in the best place because it
blocks the inhibition of c8 and clearly
after all these exchanges White's up
like four moves and development because
the dark submission button but on a
theoretical level isn't this game but
considered good for black that's why I
kind of what I was again I'm not a
Frenchie expert and I and I don't ever
play one on TV because you know how I
feel about the French but am i aren't
I'm right about that this is this is a
line that suppose to be good for black I
think that it's I mean I think Alyssa
Mel Aquino would disagree with you
because I believe she loves this opening
for white okay but I think importantly
is that humans very much struggle when
they give up a pawn for this again I've
said this before abstract idea of
compensation in the form of activity
it's not always clear where to put your
pieces how exactly the best way to
maintain set activity in the initiative
so I think that humans really struggle
with that element engines don't have our
same mortal fears and so they say okay
well you may have this pawn and I'm
quickly going to develop my pieces and
let's see how you Castle safely but on
the same on the same note right we could
flip the script and say that engines
also don't have the same fears when
defending these short positions right I
mean that's the thing that engines do
better than all of us humans combined is
gobbling a pawn that seems terribly
poisoned and then being like I got no
problem I got no emotions right I'll
defend so I agree with you it but I
think that on a I'm I'm curious again
you know what this brings up is the
question from Peter dollars yesterday
Robert is how these engines without
their opening books on remind everybody
the format there are no eCos being used
here how they consistently play
themselves into sometimes though the
very relevant theory topical theory and
other times lines that that have sort of
been worked out but they kind of work it
out amongst themselves right it's really
interesting yeah I mean there's like
stumbling into a very popular you know
maybe in this case not so popular line
but a traditional opening theory so it
is it is very fascinating how they do
that without opening books okay all
right well uh where do we want to go
I was ago the next Houdini game with
white because it's
sort of similar in the sense that there
is a attack on his d4 square but I
really don't love blacks setup oh yeah
with the g6 and fee and Ketel situation
definitely makes this a different type
of pawn to go grab because blacks dark
squares are much more potentially weak
when you've moved as you would say
Roberts Swiss cheese as you would say
when you're stealing my lines you would
say Swiss cheese right I mean that's
kind of what you're saying is blacks
position is even more precarious on the
dark squares here yeah and I'm
struggling to figure out where exactly
the Queen wants to go because sometimes
after you capture on d4 Queen d4 Knight
f3 you know you just go back to b6 and
try to say that all as well but like you
said there are some weaknesses in the
dark squares and this poem before gives
white more space I don't necessary know
you know if that pawn can become a
target yet I have to you know sit and
kind of evaluate but I mean really I
think White's play comes pretty
naturally this point Knight f3 will of
course be played the Queen I think
should go back to to b6 I don't really
see why would go to g4 I looks like a
weird square and white can also go
Bishop b2 to defend the pawn on e5 and
so the spatial advantage putting that
Bishop from b2 to d4 for example
feels quite friendly for White's
position yeah and I was just going over
a line there that maybe involved Bishop
e3 Queen c7 and the rook to c1 with
tempo but okay so white is white as
being a little more patient I actually I
think Houdini's right about that let's
over protect the e5 pawn and keep the
jury out in regards to where this Bishop
is headed because it may go directly
from g5 to f6 it may go to g5 Queen d2
and then Bishop h6 right there's all
kinds of ways for Houdini back to your
point to slow play this compensation
right Houdini isn't gonna rush it like a
human and say oh I'm down upon I think I
think I agree that this one to me feels
more like I I'm liking Houdini's chances
whereas that first French we were
looking at I guess maybe just because I
I knew that that was a theoretical line
that's supposed to be good for black to
gobble the pawn and you should be able
to defend but either way at least we're
in a dynamic affair right we spent a lot
of time here talking about Houdini's
games let's let's go over to the games
where stockfish is white we've got the
first one with a big pawn chain and
we've got the second one with a big
space advantage here we can see both of
dog vicious games as white the the two
respective positions what are your
thoughts here well in the game where
they just traded on d3 and white has
pawn chain from f2 to c5 it kind of I
feel like God Akatsuki is playing with
black I feel like I've seen him million
times and the point is that White has
this nice spatial advantage but black
has no concrete weaknesses so yes you
can keep black crew playing this move e5
eventually or perhaps now Bishop c7 will
be played supporting this ePHI break and
then the question becomes how is white
gonna do anything if you're a 3 to b4
well you also open up the a file for
black if you don't do that and go f4
well blend maybe black will put the
knight on e4 eventually f6
you instead of going g5 it's the pawns
on f4 because it's not likewise any
pieces over there on the Kings side so I
think blacks been perfectly fine here in
fact I often like blacks position at
least because when a 5 is in then all of
a sudden the pawn chain starts to feel a
little bit uncomfortable and then you
even consider going b v e4 if white
allows it mm-hmm and with that at the
structure fully changes you might see
black with a nice King side attack in
chances so I agree with you and I like
the the main Bobby has a teaching moment
that you made which was that sorry I had
to get my groove on there it was that
was that black maybe with less space has
no weaknesses that's a really important
take important takeaway for everyone at
home because sometimes people panic when
you see all your pieces over here right
on the back rank cramped a little bit
struggling for squares but that's you
know in a lot of ways that type of
activity is a very temporary situation
because there is time to unwind or to as
Bobby is saying change the pawn
structure or open the center so when you
don't have positional weaknesses that
means that your long-term future is very
good right your your stock in the long
term of this game is usually very high
because because as once you fix your
activity problem you're not worried
about anything positionally backfiring
so I think that's a really great point
all right what about this game over here
to the left where all the sudden stock
fish has said I like all my pawns on the
fourth-ranked
right I like my pawns like I like my
coffee wired and full of caffeine
really had no idea where you're going
with that one so I'm glad you just you
know change that I really just didn't
know but yeah I love whites position
there yes I love it too right you have
the two bishops so you have a dark
square Bishop wears white a black eye to
give up that one earlier and now white
controls all the shots right a five is
coming at the right moment opening the a
file
look at this Bishop on a right it is
staring down that long diagonal
preventing white from going afore which
is essential because if what you know
had two moves there and go Queen c2 and
E for all of a sudden you're just kind
of blasting through in the middle of the
board so you know it's the right moment
a5 is coming you can see it sometimes
there's a somatic sacrifice where after
a five black goes b5 I don't think
you'll see it here but the ideas that
sit controlled the d5 square and you
know further control the light squares
and try to play for some compensation
that way but as I was about to say c5 is
thematic okay you're challenging in the
center but I mean I really love White's
position because after dc5 if you take
with the B pawn on c5 then white just
goes for d5 and now you see a passed
pawn on that side of the board and he
did go B takes d5 and now b5 is just a
simple passed pawn
stop even if black goes d5 you gaze them
oh ye okay oh boy 'if I've so Bishop h3
now feels plenty good for for white yeah
and look at this two-on-one structure
that's been created over here right
again yeah this is looking one quite
difficult for black okay so if stock
fishes is is in control with the space
advantage in the first game in the
second game as we know it's we kind of
are liking Houdini now that he's gotten
e5 let's go back to the boards where
Houdini is white we have a couple of
French gambits right a couple of French
gambits a little bit of French fun and
this should be this should be an
interesting one
I love whites position on both these
boards now maybe love is a bit strong
because you got to work for my love but
the one where the bishop is on g7 we can
started with that one let's say look at
blacks position with absolutely no space
yep I don't see okay Bishop d7 calm
then what right that's my essential
question is if you okay now you can't go
Bishop d7 because it hangs the night on
d7 so I don't see what black is playing
dude sick kind of get out on that Queen
side Queen d7 was played but then you
know even now you can't go Knight takes
b6 or the Brooklyn DA's hanging you
thinkin Queen takes b6 to the rook on a
it's hanging and so if you take on c6 I
guess check back with the rook on c6 and
I have a an annoying past pawn over
there and eventually I'll go rook you
know for you're trying to get at a pawn
as well because that a pawn is weak so
maybe it's equal I wouldn't be surprised
but I think that white is slightly
better here I agree and I'm I feel like
I'm getting closer to eating my words I
guess I did kind of like whites chances
initially in that one because of the fee
and head of bishop in regards to the
gambit so I guess I'm not eating my
words I was supportive of White's
potential compensation there but I but I
uh
on that note I'm still surprised by how
well Houdini is grinding out this
position against doc fish it it feels to
me like like white is already in
position where he's playing for two
results now what about the other French
where I was more skeptical of White's
decision to go for what is theoretically
known to be an okay gambit for black but
here also White's got pressure and even
stockfish you know our own cloud
analysis directly on the live server is
kind of saying I don't even like my
position that myself is playing about
myself right me myself and Irene here
right I mean this is a this is a
position that stockfish is is
criticizing himself for playing so what
about this one where where Houdini just
played h4 well stock range is completely
undeveloped White has a huge spatial
advantage it's not clear where why black
is in a castle and you know right now
you can just say you're going h5 you
know Bishop e3 and then h5 you have all
these options so you know it's I think
black really lacks the space and that's
of course the point of the gambit and
more importantly being underdeveloped
and unn castled I really like Houdini's
chances to unleash some sort of an
attack and I don't see the counter play
at all for black you know we'll be
interesting is if after this after this
match you know this line gets a little
bit of a Renaissance we talked about
sometimes the computers are playing
theoretically relevant positions and
other times maybe they're not
but in this case if Houdini proves that
White's got compensation here I'd be
curious to know whether whether we ever
see this gambit try it again for white
at the highest level so I probably the
biggest reason it won't be is because
there's so many ways to beat the French
just choose your own flavor
right but okay let's focus on the
analysis of this one where Houdini
actually looks like he's got an edge
with the to pass V pons here so
stockfish has won the e5 pawn but maybe
at the risk of giving up the dark square
bishop what's going on here well instead
of you know blacks retrieve the Bishop
to g7 but you know we see material
equality it doesn't look that way
because blacks pawns are connected one
island whereas white has these weird and
awkward double B pawns but that said
look at the initiative it's all on the
white side you if you do capture this
pawn on b6 over the other rook can come
down to a7 and then try to apply
pressure on the f7 pawn so I think black
isn't gonna try to eat five either well
maybe after rook a7 then II five I'm not
sure you just need to get this Bishop on
c8 active you need to start pushing your
pawns that are passed and so I'm liking
white but I would not be surprised at
all of you know rook a8 here for example
trades off one pair of rooks and then
it's just like a equal position so I
mean II file a rookie also remember
everybody we are in the 10 - time
control now so suddenly we're seeing I
mean honestly I feel like we're more
likely to see more wild swings and
potential blunders by these computers
which always sounds like an oxymoron to
say blunders by the engine right but
just watching the analysis directly on
the chest comm server watching that
evaluation bar on your left here and the
show sliding up and down so rapidly
tells you that I don't think the engines
understand exactly what's going on here
for either side so that makes it
exciting and has this has this
anticipating a moment that there could
be crazy the other way go ahead I was a
here in 97 the point is that now the
rooks are disconnected yep and he has to
give up the the Brooke for two pieces
but then efore follows it up but then I
think you can go Bishop f1 or rook takes
d5 and then I think it's bishop f1 is
slightly better because that way you get
the default D pawn back without giving
up your beep on so Roop takes D 7e for
Bishop f1e takes f3 and then
probably Brook takes d5 there's no way
white should ever lose that position so
yeah I mean even down the exchange
there's not enough left for the rooks to
target but still as far as what happened
there with White's pressure and
initiative it feels like stockfish has
already seen the worst of it and he and
he's doing okay here I don't think stuff
fishy was gonna lose either as black
though speaking of pressure and
initiative I guess we should flip the
game to the one well yeah I don't know
there's so many interesting games right
yeah I know I don't let's go to the one
the other one where Houdini's white
though again just cuz I want to see this
this French attack getting crazy here
with the knight on chief or the Queen on
h5 whoa is Bishop g6 a move in this
position what is happening I think you
have to start at Bishop d1 just the
plate
cuz Bishop u6 is a little too wild a
little too frisky Dani little too heavy
hashtag Danny's getting frisky but if
you and Knight f5 here for example I
mean black's knight is coming once the
defense at some point white is going
Knight f6 check and just sacrificing yep
on and going Bishop f4 to e5 and things
like that and you know there's gonna be
problems along the e-file because the
King is on casters of King f8 wow I
wasn't expecting that because now Bishop
e3 made me and I'm Bishop to c5 with
check a knight of six is still possible
here I like what's there's also this
sort of outside idea Robert of a4 and b5
to open up the b4 diagonal against the
King definitely I mean that that's for
sure planner I was trying to do without
sacrificing a pawn but I mean clearly
Houdini has no issue sacrificing yeah
play tag amp it now is giving up another
pawn at Bishop f6 EF since Queen f6 but
I think a very important note is that
King safety at least to me is paramount
and so even if the engines say something
and again I don't have an evaluation in
front of me even if it says that black
is okay and if it only says like
something black is equal or slightly
worse I think black is significantly
worse because these engines don't have
the same depth they do when you let them
sit and run for 30 minutes they're on
agreed a hundred percent and just for
the record the evaluation likes white
anyway and it's under time pressure so
with the practical factor of an attack
against the King being harder to defend
when you don't have time on the clock
I'm like in Houdini's chanson to get
some big wins here as white in these
French games okay look we got all the
game
are crazy let's go back to this really
weird one that's become totally closed
up this game where stockfish is white
okay well this reminds me of Houdini
stockfish where Houdini was white though
kind of game of the event this far yeah
white is clearly better the position is
totally locked up but only white has
this break with like an eventual b6 plan
yep I'm even also I guess you know if
you get lucky at some point capture on
d4 and then break open with c5 or ephod
depending on which way black recaptures
button
I don't know b6 is is got to be a threat
at some moment yeah and maybe black
can't even put a book on b6 attempting
to sacrifice in exchange if you had to
and just to make sure that the blockade
and that all the pieces don't get going
and the other game we're stockfish is
white speaking of King safety stock
bridges up a piece what happened here
he's up a piece but his King is under a
massive attack from Houdini Bueller well
it looks like wait now he gives up the
rook on e4 that is a this is what
happens when computers don't have time
take that depth perception take that
easy talk fish it's going yep let say g5
trying to close the position up on the
King side even though it's not
particularly close I think black is
winning I mean how can you black not be
winning if to passed pawns you're gonna
have a rook on e5 I guess why he's gonna
try to go some Knight c4 and 93 and
close up the position but again it
doesn't work I mean yeah there's no way
possible
rook d5 at some point this is I mean
dude there's two passed pawns on e and F
and you have a rook behind it and I've
heard that I me up though what is going
on Houdini is about to show his strength
in the faster time controls already
surprising the world I think by making
it to this final I had a comodo Houdini
might be about to show that he's the
better blitz player over over stockfish
because because I'm looking at three
games that might be victories for
Houdini Robert yeah this is very bizarre
but perhaps is a blockade here this 93
and King on f2 if there's pawns aren't
moving any time soon but okay you know
at some point it really feels like work
out four will come but even if we're
gonna for comes in King g3 main route g4
check yeah I can i play Brooke f4 and
and King g3 and
sac on g4 to make sure I get through I
think that is a winning strategy because
you know why can't do anything White's
kind of it has to sit tight if one
doesn't go with b5 within c5 is weak so
here comes rook at 4 and now King g3
rubgy for Czech makes perfect sense
yeah there it is the idea look at us
coming up with the computer idea
boomtown Robert uh you can be my you can
be my computer wingman anytime look at
that look at that spite sack by
stockfish gives up the pawn on g6 for
nothing nothing but a check that's funny
I don't care who you are that's funny
Danny I agree with you on the other
stock fish game by the way with your
rook b6 just sitting the rook there and
sacrificing I feel like there's nothing
that uh that stockfish conducive stop is
in big trouble I don't know how the
other Young's are going whoa in okay so
somehow which in the in the Houdini
stock first came with the two bishops
first rook and Bishop it looks like
black has made a bit of progress but I
guess it's just a draw because there's
no way to actually push this deep on
without so yeah piece but all White's
got the a plum Black's got the D pawn go
ahead the other game or Houdini's white
yeah this is where Houdini has made a
huge progress look at this now all of a
sudden white is up a pawn at least
temporarily blacks all blacks remaining
pawns are very weak and so what is going
to move they're moving so fast cuz they
have no time everybody this is ten
minute rapid chess what happens when
computers can't tap into that depth
we're gonna find out today no you have
to go rook takes 84 rook takes g6 with
check then you move the rook away and so
white goes up upon other a forest
hanging but importantly there's 2.0 but
there's a deep on may hang right you can
bring the rook to d6 and right as we say
it he plays it not he it right I think
this should be a draw because at the
right moment black will sacrifice the
bishop for the two pawns uh-huh and rook
and Bishop versus rook is a theoretical
drama it's already in a winning position
another example where grandmasters may
lose the defense but with the table
basin indium will never lose it
absolutely but and so we have our first
result Houdini has one as black
as black let that sink in everybody and
it was the game that we were talking
about where black had just completely
turned the tables and with this very
nice rook she for idea managed to break
down the blockade against the king and
Knight and eventually the Queen on the
board happened I'm just like shocked
right now that we are about to see this
massive upset in the computer chess
championship with Houdini taking down
stock fish look where we're going I
wouldn't be surprised if in the game
where the two businesses the rook that
if somehow white becomes better I mean
it sounds very weird because you know
rook is more valuable
it's a rook versus Bishop and pawn right
but somehow I feel like you know things
can go wrong if anything goes wrong for
anyone they go wrong for black and the
King runs in oh there goes the f3 trying
to get into e4 maybe but yeah I mean
should just be a draw for sure but
somehow you know if any it's going wrong
for anyone's going wrong for black so
the stock fish have any chance in this
game it comes back to that one really
weird one with the closed position but
as we establish you up but the rook
would go to be six and there's Houdini
stealing our ideas classic Houdini and
and again if the idea everybody is that
the bishop coming to a5 and taking the
rook is probably not going to be enough
to win because black will just
immediately blockade all chances of
opening the position which means again I
just I see stockfish has really fallen
behind here yeah and I was gonna say the
only chance to win is by taking on d4
and trying to pawn break and I was would
also be interesting to see if he takes
d4 but I guess I'm blocked in one
allowed five and hoping that Bishop but
if if he five ever was okay now it's a
draw there's no possible way anyone's
doing like you just move around 4
million moves this reminds me of a Cara
Nakamura playing Bullitt and ICC back on
the day except no way to flag somebody
when there's an increment right that's
like a carros worst nightmare like hey
carla has Picaro has stress dreams about
trying to flag someone and they have an
increment and he doesn't understand why
they keep getting time on the clock so
all right so what about the other game
Houdini okay let's say this one's gonna
be a draw okay
Wow stockfish managed to hold on and
both those games is black because this
is now an easy draw whenever you have
your King in front of the F Paul and
everybody
there's no way to lose these we're
getting so that's a draw and this one
without scam bishops will also be a draw
so full focus comes back to whether
there's any sort of magically
manufacturer breakthrough here but it
looks like the answer will be no which
means we will have three games to run in
this round Robert and the lone decisive
game right here on the board you can see
where it ended with checkmate for
Houdini as black that's gonna be the
tale that tells us why Houdini has a
full point lead heading into the 5-2
portion yeah this is really shocking
stuff because I I mean didn't we spoke
about it we thought that stop fish was
far and away the best engine but we did
see you know in that crucial round eight
when Houdini won one of the two games
against stuff we saw well you know it
this end you can really fight despite
the fact sock fish was running away with
the preliminary stage and here in this
these games that are left okay one game
was officially drawn that rook and pawn
ending the opposite code Bishop endgame
will be a draw in a second and this game
where there are so many pieces left and
looks like they're playing checkers you
know it's funny because humans would
just go King g7 King eh eh can you see
haven't you really nothing can be done
but they don't want to do that by
everyone because the content factor if
they just repeat in the same exact way
it'll be a draw by repetition so they're
gonna find the most creative way to
reach a 50 move draw on this game it's
actually gonna be quite entertaining if
you're into that sort of thing hash tag
Flight of the Conchords what you're into
but by the way what are you into Papa
bottom is my my my rhymes are bottomless
I was hoping so of course they are you
know me I accidentally rhyme what I'm
talking about chess it's like it just
comes out of me when I get on the mic my
rhymes are tight alright this is just
this is just boring now but it is funny
to see them not take a draw back to the
one that you said is also a draw do dogs
code bishops we should take bets on the
Kree like what will the final position
be right we've already seen somebody
give up a corner pawn and stalemate
themselves instead of doing it to the
other person so just like this one being
black with King and G pawn versus just a
white King like on g1 yeah yeah yeah so
that's the craziest possible ending to
this right let's go with the crazy as
possible ending is black stalemates
white with an extra G pawn and the white
King's on G
I'll raise you one here and say the
craziest possible ending of this really
close position is that stockfish loses
his white because his contempt gets so
strong that he he plays c5 just like I
said oh my god he actually did it uh is
that gonna happen doctor he's gonna find
a way to lose this game because he's
that frustrated by the draw wow that
would be I mean that's huge think about
it well actually now my wife might win
whoa
if we get a decisive result here how
amazing would that be I mean it's all so
ridiculous because it was just a dead
draw like just moving the King around so
this is this is insanity White's gonna
win this game dude
I yeah what b6 at some point is gonna
come you know Bishop a4 now is probably
spinning he's gonna back up the rook and
then at some point the b6 happens and
this Bishop on a8 is is basically
trapped right so that means the black
rook is forever chained down to the
eighth rank and we'll see if Houdini can
get himself out of this box locked with
chains am i right that was that was well
played I've been waiting for that like
can I retire now I've been waiting for
that all week and Houdini get out of
this box
locked with chains time for me to a
fidget spinner Houdini
retired because this is like an insult
to chest how this just happened it was a
complete dead draw the content factor is
high we know there was no reason to move
a piece from c5 though you're right the
only reason they do is because they
don't want the draw but now somehow
someway okay all the other games are
done by the way everybody remember
Houdini one as black and then drew both
games as white that here comes b6
White's ready to pick up sticks wins
apiece and goes on to win this game that
is bananas those bananas Danny I'm upset
about this honestly yes it's like a
melee imagine stockfish goes on to win
this match is because Houdini
essentially through this game that's
like how I see it and I understand that
you know throughout the whole event
there's been contempt factors been on
there having some strange things
occurring but there was no
way ever but ever ever that blacks have
lost this game by that's a we're could
have sacrificed a queen left the Queen
of c-5 that somehow lost the Queen and
c5 rights still not you can give the
lock pawn structure well in fact on the
same note though I guess you could say
that the game that Houdini one had
enough rook shuffles right that it was
borderline a draw to right and
eventually there's a breakthrough that
White had a space advantage the whole
time in this game though you're right
black had no reason to move a piece from
c5 yet in doing so gave white
unnecessary winning chances yeah this is
I mean this is how dick change that I
wonder I remember these are humans like
I mean these aren't humans these are
computers like and the and the way that
they're set up in terms of what they
value I I wish I was a smart scientist
but I'm not I'm not Robert I'm just I'm
at a loss from work I can't be a
scientist dad okay I don't want your
laugh dude I'm gonna loss for words as
well so how do we explain that stockfish
wins this game it's fascinating to me I
think I think let's remind everybody why
Robert and I feel this way we're gonna
go back to move whatever hundred it's
amazing I'm only going back to move like
a hundred and eighteen right because
because this game is already in the 200s
okay look at this okay so this position
here for example is what we're talking
about okay every single square is
blockaded this is like a Sam you know
Sam Cooke puzzle book right I mean this
is a this is a position that is as
Robert said it's checkers okay there was
no way black loses this game the moves
that should be played or any form of
shuffling that your heart desires yet
black to shuffle in a different way or
to avoid an exact three move repetition
removes the rook from c5 and then never
puts it back there in Ewa tably sorry
that brought me back i misclicked there
inevitably getting us to the position
here that you see where white was able
to sacrifice the C pawn
which I to be fair predicted at first
that it would be like stock fish stock
fishes contempt getting him to lose the
game but it turns out it was actually
exactly the breakthrough white needed
Robert because it opens up the C file
enough to give white entry points into
blacks position and suddenly it's very
clear that only black can lose with the
trap Bishop on a eight the two on one
majority for white and and Bob's your
uncle so so again that's why Rob and I
are freaking out because you go back to
this move here on on move a hundred and
sixteen and black plays rook to c8
rather than extend his hand for a draw
so you know I'm not even sure what to
say about it Robert besides you look
really good today buddy that's it
well you said Sam Cooke and I merely was
thinking of twisting the night away not
the chest puzzle creator but it is Sam
Cooke right the chess puzzle creator
creator it yeah and Sam Cooke is also
was a famous singer who was killed in
under mysterious circumstances
why do you have to get into that you
know how I feel about talking about
mysterious circumstances made no Sam
Cooke Sam Lloyd right now I'm Koka Sam
Lloyd is the puzzle maker I think so uh
you're right so what is Sam Lloyd cuz
I'm thinking of you were trying to twist
the night away even though it's only you
know 10 a.m. by you so subconsciously I
always have yeah if we pull up the game
we're hoo-dee-hoo needing one yep
and then there's that game was a
particular note not just because
starfish didn't throw the game but I
think the next round is starting so I
just wanna make this point really
quickly if you go to move 23 getting
there
white went up upon the pawn a 5 was
sacrificed by black because the rook
were put in the center there's pressure
along the e3 Square and blacks activity
and the harmony of its pieces more than
offset the cost of just that pawn that's
very thematic in this opening like I
said the gada confer
well I know has played as many times as
black and so it's more important to have
the piece on the right squares then have
the equal material so let's start things
Rico I just want to highlight again a
similar theme attic moment there happen
after ricotta cops he got that big
build-up and played the mood qi5 and
then and then and then broke through on
f4 and like you said all the blacks
pieces came to life and
and then even lovely you say gotta
constantly did that because I've been
talking about gotta gotta calm Sookie
alright so now we're in the five minute
and two second increment time control so
now it's getting really fast really
hectic and where do you want to start
Danny which game has caught your eye
I literally right now I'm just I'm just
gonna get all the games pulled up here
you choose you're already looking at the
positions I'm keeping our our show alive
here okay running more games than any
human should ever have to observe let's
look at stock fish white against Houdini
in the game that would we just CD take C
5 Dan is this ringabel
hold on is it a tirage well I haven't
even seen it yet I just heard you say
the moves d take C 5 and I knew what you
were talking about do you recognize this
oh my gosh why do they keep doing this
why do they keep doing this Houdini is
throwing the mesh I'm calling it a rig
right now believe me I don't think
Houdini's throwing the match I think his
his creator really wants to win and
submitted an optimized version for these
rapid time controls as we asked and I
think every developer did again can I
get a confirmation that Pete did every
engine in our tournament submit an
optimized version for our format so
before we get complaining or decide hey
rapid time controls or whatever I mean
to me this is the most exciting this is
first of all the most excitement I've
ever had watching two computers go at it
in any form of action chess or otherwise
that's firstly secondly what was that
Hugh Jackman movie would take the robots
those aren't computers that was ma'am
controlled robot that's um alright
iron that's what is it well I don't know
I I give up
but it's Hugh Jackman so who cares just
kidding love you Hugh he is that he is a
full package that guy he is only whole
package apparently on fire and Komodo
were actually optimized sending their
most optimized version for this oh
really so fire and Komodo were the only
ones who optimized so it was different
than what I thought so right now this is
just that's even better for Houdini just
stock fish versus Houdini straight up
right now Houdini's playing better in
rapid time controls period okay and sax
also sent one
more last minute though all right so
where are we going in this beautiful
part of the program Robert helped guide
me to analysis that the people can enjoy
well we guess it's gonna get harder and
harder with five minutes it these
they're gonna be playing faster and
faster but I got to say stockfish looks
like he has his best chances to maybe
win games is white here although these
double D pawns in this one game are
absolutely terrible yeah that's a that
is an ugly set of pawns they're an ephah
but white is currently up not one but
two pawns however I think black has
proper compensation for those pawns
because the two bishops the only way to
defend the C pawn is not an a4 and the
nine and a four is now under attack so
once white loses this 8th Tsugumi to c5
pawn I think black is completely
equalized because the only extra pawn
then is one of the double e pawns and
that is not enough from advanced ok what
about this other game here where
stockfish is white now here stockfish
has the bishop pair but what's the
concrete advantage he can get from that
I guess the other big issue is Houdini's
under under developed but it seems like
Houdini should be okay in this one is
black yeah Houdini looks to be doing all
right
the key here is that yes what has the
two bishops but black has already
instead of having a pondless and c6
having a space disadvantage black has a
space advantage because that pawns on c4
right so eventually black can consider
making moves like Knight to b6 or you
know trying to trade off the light
square bishop and then go Knight a four
and kick this Queen out from you three
of course I would start maybe with h6 or
Mei moving the knife from f6 but okay no
and I just highlighted that idea that if
the knight comes to b6 that would go to
a4 and one of the things I want to point
out Robert mentioned the space advantage
always in our interest of keeping the
bigger picture in mind something we have
to do as chess players black has a
potential three on two on the Queen side
so keep an eye on that potential endgame
situation so and of course white has a
four on five but White's pawn structure
is currently being held back by black
having a strong grip over this e4 square
okay well both games are going super
fast we can see the other game here with
stock fishes white let's go to the games
where stock fish is black and Houdini
has the white pieces what are his
winning chances here where in the world
Carmen Sandiego well oh I don't even
know so right now it looks like White
has the two bishops that is Houdini and
Black is the worst pawn structure but
that being said it will be difficult to
to make a real progress because those
pawns are well defended importantly this
White King on h1 is kind of stuck for
the time being black can eventually
consider going King f8 c e7 g5 is
certainly an idea for black at the right
moment to kick this bishop off the
diagonal so right now I think that black
is forced to remove the bishop from the
protection of f6 white can consider
capturing on f6 but then we'll see
opposite colored bishops and whether or
not that's enough for a win for white
now remains to be seen uh sorry I
blacked out you were providing way too
much chess knowledge for for anybody
like me to ever be able to handle so
what about the other game where we now
have a knight on d4 and what in the
world is going on here well why don't
they recapture the piece on d4 and after
Bishop d4 black is a big choice either
go Bishop c5 and offer more trades or go
Queen back to b7 to defend the e4 Knight
I think that white is doing pretty well
here
because I'm showing not a huge fan of
these Knights on e4 yes they look kind
of menacing but the same time they often
get stuck there and the right moment
capture them and then transition into an
imbalance a game with that tends to
favor white but for the time being black
looks to be doing solidly here and I
mean Bishop c5 for example seems exactly
perfectly reasonable as a pawn sacrifice
it looks like a pawn sacrifice really
only temporary if Bishop takes e4 pawn
takes before
Queeny for there might be some problems
in the diagonal so yeah real problems
real diagonal problems okay well I agree
that stockfish and if we look at the
other game here directly to our left
with stock becoming black he's up he's
not up a pawn but the obstacle of Bishop
ending and the pawn majority on the
Kings side is okay for him I don't
expect this King to really be in that
much danger here given that this bishop
isn't getting active on the Y square
diagonals anytime soon but I
think if we predict this first one's
gonna be a draw just obstacle bishops
they're now trading Queens looks likely
then the question will be can stock fish
get something weird and dynamic here in
the in the position with his knight on
e4 and Bishop on c5 back to the games
for Houdini's white or sorry stock which
is white yeah the stock which went up in
exchange in one of the games the games
that originally had the double e pawns
now all of a sudden white is up in
exchange for a pawn that run b6
will be well placed but white can
immediately go Bishop to e4 trade off
the light square bishop and try to turn
this into a full point yeah they're not
really I don't really see how to do that
though I mean you know if you go before
which I think is best just take on e4
rookie four where is white gonna make
progress
yeah the bishop being defended by the a
pond and the a pawn defending the bishop
right it's a mutually dependent
dysfunctional relationship the that
looks very easy for black to hold this I
agree so it's one of those positions
where despite the evaluation being
almost a full point here for white
everyone can see on the left plus 0.93
something but where's the beef right
Roberts a meat-eater and he wants it
there is no beef yeah I mean I'm hungry
so I'm not really seeing I think white
can build up we saw Fizbo do that in the
preliminary stage where the extra
exchange we thought it would be a draw
and all of a sudden was winning
especially with contempt factors on high
and whoa in the other stockfish game the
last move was pawn f5 to G takes f 4 I
was like what where did that pawn on
that 4 come from but look at this past
pawn on c2 Danny
mm-hmm again it's one of those positions
where if the content factor is really
high they don't want to make a draw to
me only black can win a position like
this because even if your King runs over
to d3 the black King can run over to h3
perhaps and try to get this H pawn so
both sides this big issue is really
though the white has this massive
majority UE F and D pawns here if white
can maybe just ignore the C pawn and
play King f3 maybe e4 and try to just
mobilize the center majority yeah
exactly rooks III came so in short order
and now this III pawn isn't stopping his
tracks
if you go King II for well then where's
your king going out for that or a king
before I probably can just go King of 7
or even King a try but
t5 look at that but now King at five so
if you go my take on these we just trade
all them that pair of rooks because the
e3 is my worry is that maybe White's
passed pawns will be faster than blacks
especially if I can get King before and
King d4 and then maybe E and F I guess
they don't agree because they're not
trading on e6 they being the stock fish
today the problem there is you might
lose if you went takes a taking you for
cut yeah I need the b-pawn runs so fast
there you're right okay okay but with
this trade happening I seems like
petering out to an equal rook ending
similar to what we saw in the 15 - time
controlled where we had four Brook
endings is likely here and and with that
the most likely result being a draw okay
what about the other games we we still
have similar scenarios that we left
behind although stock fish is probably
the game with that has the best winning
chances overall of any game is this one
where stock fish is black and has the
night versus the bishop but the rook
much better placed on the second ranked
yeah that looks like as well not I don't
wait anymore because if Bishop takes d5
eat 65 maybe qg3 and the King goes to d4
and try to take up this d5 pawn so I
think why is just in the nick of time
although h2 is also hanging so it should
be I feel like it's a draw because the
the pawns are so bad and right now you
can't protect both be pawn and D pawn if
you look d3 I go route B 8 euro b3 or AB
d8 so I'm taking this pawn this should
be a draw
so let's top of the game back where
stock Fischer's up the exchange it
that's still quite interesting because
the game where Houdini other game
Houdini's wise opposite called bishops
looks to be equal but the game where it
stop fishes up the exchange use make him
sort of this bow like progress here
cross eyes cross-eyed clown at all now
that is a great way of putting it some
Fizbo sighs progress but I mean how do
you actually make progress I have blacks
it's the King on G ok so what if we can
orchestrate a trade of rooks so let's
say we get the
rooks doubled on the D file rather than
the e-file cuz the e7 square is guarded
then we put a rook on D 7 and force
black to simplify if we get one of the
rooks off although now with pawns stuck
on dark squares like the pawn on g5 to
me that makes it even more likely it's a
draw because that's an easy pawn target
for the bishop so all right I'm gonna
stop pretending like I see a clear way
for white to win this I don't I don't
either but seems like progress has been
made because your idea of getting the
rook on the D file is good if you can
get that rook on d7 and then put
shuffling over then try double in the
seventh rank also to be noticed if that
second rook can reach the last rank
it'll be checkmate right from GA check
check other is me so a black skin can be
ensnared if things go wrong however I
just I'm not seeing it right like look
at this rook going back and forth at
some point you can even consider go up
to b1 and trying to get the Jeep on from
behind and these end games are
especially with this a pawn and the
Brooklyn from b7 and up to b4 + b3
I don't know how progress to me maids I
think the advantage the huge advantage
that an engine might give here I don't
know it's saying probably I'm guessing
something like 1.2 are about there yep
that notion is overstated no you're
right though as much as that we like the
pawn on g5 because it holds h6 and f6
you have this constant threat of coming
to the back rank and mating as we
highlighted the moment that pawn
touchdown on the g5 square it was stuck
to a dark square everybody which means
it's just a sitting duck target and
Robin already highlighted black as is
never never too far from from going from
behind to the G spot over here and
taking advantage of that so let's now
now things are getting a little less
clear because the a6 pawn is coming down
and the only way to hold from here if
you're black is you know you need to get
to this G pawn or I mean you take the e
pawn then just should be in draw
immediately yeah by winning the e pawn
you just see your work in the F file and
no progress would be made he's you know
attacked his pawn on g5 so right now
Bishop c1 I guess I like what stockfish
is doing though this attempt to try to
sacrifice the e pawn to get the 7th rank
you know and it's everything he can do
to try to use the power of having two
rooks while black only has one he does
manage to get these rooks on the seventh
rank this is making me think
that with time pressure ensuing we're
much more likely to see a weird a weird
if landslide why are you winning Daniel
ie pond right because II 5 is a huge
threat yeah the only ways p5e 6 is to do
something like king jade but after king
jaden of rooks code the 8th to rank and
go from be able D 8 yep and here they
come the rook something the rooks are
coming the piece is gone boomtown
stockfish found a way to grind down
Houdini in this endgame Fizbo style okay
the game where her stock fish was white
in the which was the the other game
that's already in in a draw so we won't
even worry about that stock fish is
about to take down this game where he
managed to outplay black and win the
rook what are Houdini's chances as white
Robert how do you say non exist in any
other way there there's dead draws in
both games and the in one game is rook
in three versus working three all in the
same side of the board if anything it
looks like Houdini is almost getting
himself in trouble with like a weird
mating net with the with the F pawn no I
guess I guess it's just gonna be a draw
okay wait a second what the other game
Houdini is up two pawns now I didn't see
how that happened but it's opposite
colored bishop a
brought I said earlier look at the bond
yep right the King just can stay on the
H okay always giving up the pawn that
doesn't matter but yeah point everybody
is this Bishop can stay here sacrifice
itself for the a pawn the moment it goes
there and if you touch down on the h8
square that is a draw despite being down
a full bishop and a pawn if you don't
know your theoretical draws now you do
that is a draw so how will this one end
with their contempt factor I don't know
we can use our imaginations to fantasize
about something crazy but either way
it's gonna be a draw which means with
stockfish taking the full point in the
game where he did manage to win the
brook stockfish is gonna take a one-game
match lead headed into the even faster
blitz portion
I really hope Houdini gets its two
because this is ridiculous
shouldn't have been tied going into this
round and now okay this actually lost
this game that's so be it but should not
be down you know point should be even
after this loss
yeah super super crazy to even be in a
position where stockfish is leading this
match right now if you're just joining
us there was some wild and crazy
controversy in the last game where in
the last round where Houdini essentially
lost himself a game due to due to the
way computers think about things weird
ways sometimes okay nothing else to say
right yeah this is just gonna be a draw
yep looks that way
hopefully they end this one soon because
the next round is three minute plus two
second increment if I'm not mistaken so
it's getting faster the action is
heating up and we'll see if who didn't
he could pull a comeback because they
mean the game is remaining
okay stop fishy fishy won the game with
white Drude the other game where Houdini
was white and now this game is a dead
drop but that leaves stop a point in the
three-two section Danny I don't know
like is the quicker time control
favoring out of these engines I'm not
sure I mean I thought it was I mean the
10/2 portion showed Houdini generally
outplay stock fish all around remember
not only did he did he blow that game
that he should have drawn but Houdini
also won a game that round and I think
if my memory is correct we felt like
Houdini was in charge of the other games
as well right so in the 10 to portion it
seemed like magical pun intended with
for Houdini the magician right but in
the 5-2 portion it's been anything but
anything but magical and now he will be
headed into the 3-2 portion down a point
because this game is just a matter of a
matter of time a matter of just being
cordial I guess always funny to see the
evaluation bar still think the white is
winning and of course that we know that
engines they are hooked up to the table
base self there no one no one's gonna
blow this game don't worry about it and
I say this game and where black will be
up a bishop which would be hilarious
right wise first a bond then another
bond then the bishop and then it's gonna
be a draw yeah well there's not going to
be much of a break everybody so don't go
anywhere we're gonna find out who will
win the first ever chess calm computer
Chess Championship in in probably the
shorter side of a half an hour here I
think right we've got
three to portion next which will be over
before you know it and then it's on to
bullet and unless Houdini pulls an upset
game in one of the next two rounds
stockfish will maintain a full game lead
and win the match so crazy crazy stuff
can't wait you haven't met guys one of
the pawns they're good know you may be
right with that you may win the the
crazy prediction of the day with
anticipating that Houdini will give up
everything I wish they could just shake
hands though yep it's you know they're
gonna shuffle for another 50 moves and
give another pawn another 50 moves well
we'll let them shuffle here and bring up
the match standings to be a little
bigger for everybody and just remind
them that we have three two and one two
right around the corner this is your
chance to grab some popcorn or a snack
while you're at it could you order me a
pizza because Papa bear's hungry but
Robert has is a meat-eater he's hungry
for some beef he didn't get as much beef
as he wanted that round but we did get
one decisive result which is why you see
the one-game lead for four stockfish at
this point this is getting a little
boring with this game let me remind
everybody what they're playing for
Robert because again for those who are
just joining us and missed the first 72
hours this is the format we've talked
about it a few times no opening books
which leads to some awesome and
interesting and creative sometimes
dubious opening approaches no draw
offers or resignations but table bases
are on a twenty five hundred dollar
prize fund we will be donating if
stockfish wins I guess that just goes to
the global chess community who basically
worked together to maintain stockfish as
everyone's favorite engine but Robert
sorry to cut you off there buddy just
wanted to remind people of what they are
watching go ahead and and tell me what
you were gonna say I don't want to say
anything you said pizza and meat and I
got really hungry so then I started
thinking about what I would want after
this match is over right for some late
lunch I don't want this classic always
thinking about where his next meal is
coming from
you know I mean you're home bites it's
been this way Danny that's insulting you
know I have I'm self-conscious over here
you know you have the metabolism of a
small
Armie okay it doesn't matter in fact
when you were out here for the speeches
championship finals the last matches
last year that was the best right was
after we would be exhausted we would go
get go get like a massive meal with tons
of wings and you know I don't even man
I'm so hungry right now I the arena what
did we get yeah we got a big old chicken
burrito
it was just what listen come on babies
but this could this could have lasted
like several hundred moves it could have
gone on I think 159 is is what we'll
take so we'll leave it at that
Grandmaster Robert has we are now moving
into the three-two portion the gloves
are our if any gloves that are still on
are coming off not even Tito Jackson is
wearing his gloves at this point all the
cards are on the table insert other
unnecessary cliche references let's just
say we're moving into the final time
controls Robert your thoughts on how you
expect 3 2 and 1/2 to go well definitely
more blunders definitely as we've seen
in the previous games if the contempt
factor is high there gonna be some weird
losses in positions that should never be
lost as you can tell I'm still very
bitter that hoody threw away that game
you need to make like Elsa right now and
let it go let it go I would let it go if
you hit that note way better
you look like strikeout King Adam done
on that note anyway I can I can hit let
it go I say my kids and I by the way
busted out a karaoke machine you have to
sing hazel dominate the karaoke machine
dude it is adorbs let it go I'm gonna
about to like leave you off don't you
shush your mouth ok well we're waiting
for uh you you like yourself some
karaoke right I love some I know that's
why I said shut your mouth cuz I know
you really love it I know you love
karaoke
I do but I'm not gonna be seeing a lot
of on-air here because you know I'm not
a singer I don't get paid to sing do I I
don't get paid to do any of this I'm
still waiting for my first paycheck from
chest comm so that's just
that's just awkward that you're bringing
that up but round four is under way it
is here we go here we go here we go
let's get the show get the show
stockfish as white stockfish as white
Houdini as white Houdini as white one
engine one desire well that's pretty
good actually I was kind of into that so
yeah a little movie a little movie voice
a taraji and a oh my gosh she turned the
opening books off and take away their
time and every engine is a dubious
opening player come on guys pull it
together which game do we want to see
the tirage uh I'd really don't want to
see the tirage but it might make sense
to stay there just because you know
three to QuickTime control we'll see
maybe instead of you know white winning
every single game I pretty sure why he's
won every single game in tirage thus far
yeah you quoted yesterday heading into
day three that white was three and oh
and I'm pretty sure we got a couple more
victories and goal might have been
involved in a couple of those but Danny
look at both stockfish white games
yes I'm clear of there right now Tosh's
so I think Houdini wants to lose two
games with black this round one wasn't
enough last time so yeah and the reason
we're so critical of the structure
everybody won it's a dubious opening
even if you have your II Co book turned
on but you're looking at a position
where black will have isolated Queen
pawns defending a positional disaster at
best most the time they lose the D pawn
when these openings are playing as we're
about to see Houdini do and just
happened on more to our right Robert
take a breath buddy I don't want you
know I know how you get about dubious
opening we thanks Danny
they implant Queenie seven the other
games okay now it could be sassy let's
see the engines can't make up their mind
I mean we know White's just up a healthy
pawn here but you got a deal with f2 at
least probably just III and black will
play Knight f6 to gain a tempo right
some really quick developments I'm
liking this version a bit more but I
still hate it so I'm you know I do see
the silver lining alright let's go to
the games where Houdini is white gelly
sure Houdini is white we see a button
Nik it was a semi slob watt Vinick and
you'll notice that white has a ton of
pawns on the kingside and black doesn't
but black has a ton of pawns the
queenside
and white has two fewer from the sea to
a file so it's automatic it's an opening
line it gets really crazy this has been
you know humans have looked at this
really in-depth it's up to you know 35
moves and things like that it's a very
well researched line so in yeah ray Rob
so eat your heart out right yeah exactly
and then in the other game it was a
Queen's Indian defense and it's more of
a tense structure in the center where
the pawn to c5 the pawn before they're
both gonna remain there for a while
seeing you know who's gonna flinch first
black should try to go rook c8 95 okay
when mattify first but same idea we
actually saw this structure yesterday
right you put the knight on a 5 to open
the bishop sometimes black can also
shoot for f5 if you really want to pry
this thing open exactly that's 100%
correct and here we go rook c8 is the
natural follow-up you're gonna try to
take over the C file okay Bishop e7
first trying to put pressure on the D
file first that always makes sense but
the essential point is it's kind of like
a grünfeld e in a sense where right
white gets thinner and from the D to H
file white as in a pawn majority but in
the a and B file is black will get the
two-on-one so that's a you know I like
that as time goes on that favors black
more and more in the inter in the kind
of the middle game structure it
definitely favors white because again
piece is preferring to be in the center
so the pawns so for the time being I
think White's chances are decent you
made a great point saying it's kind of
like a reverse Grunfeld right because
you don't have the dark square bishop
fee and kill you have the light scored
one but that's you know a constant
dynamic of chess sometimes you give your
opponent an advantage so that you have
something to attack and when you have
effective ways to undermine those pawns
you can play these types of positions
despite white having more space but
let's focus on this bought vinick's
loved one because this is by the way i
sweared this position is still theory
and they figured it out like all on
their own in blitz without ec oh right
this position is I've seen this before
or maybe it's just so similar to the
idea that black eventually you know
despite having nothing to hold on to on
the kingside uses all those open files
to get counter play and white
as white uses the center eventually
comes after the naked and afraid' black
king on c8 so am i right maybe okay no
way it's Theory anymore but I felt like
we worked far from it there now you're a
hundred percent right it looks like a
theoretical position because it's been
studied so deeply and players using
engines you know to the nth degree at
this moment but right now black has
equalized the material what is always
nerve-racking and these end games is H
pong right right if pieces get traded
off and a king of pong game let's say
the white king will shoot over to the
Queen side use the H pawn as a decoy and
white is winning in King and pawn
endings right that said no way the black
is trading off all the pieces yep
however roopd Ford has just been seen
the c4 pawn is quickly falling or
quickly falling under threat I should
rephrase and so I'm like b3 here might
already just be like kind of really
awesome well you do have to be three
right your mind e3 singing I I don't
know you you put me on the spot I hate
when you do that
just kidding well maybe there's might
have 3ch and this maybe I was being a
little harsh but like room d6 exactly
looks like Houdini is gonna show stock
fishes muscles here this is like Queen
takes c4 no not Queen takes c4 but is f4
can i play a four if I were to get a
computer move yeah well now you can even
sacrifice the exchange on d3 and have
the Queen at night go to work against
this King here that's wide open but then
the Queen goes to d5 actually this is
now this is nothing better for white I
think maybe King is much safer now for
black because once you take with a pawn
on c4 you permanently blockade that C
file so the key on c7 is actually much
better shape than it wasn't a second ago
that said this poem before is it once
again quality of pawns over quantity of
pawns yes white is up upon but that beat
pot is the best pot on the board and
what in the world H for allowing a
discovered check that what I guess it
didn't matter you're losing the C pawn
no matter what but now blacks is much
better
Black is just clearing the C file the
King won't be in danger and the b-pawn
the be pawns got problems wait Brooksie
to check solving problems I mean
or Brooks III person then well you're
just allowing Queen d7 and Queen d8 what
the this is this is that means this is
crazy
it must be at all right there's no other
way you can allow that but it stockfish
calculated it's nothing but a bunch of
tickle over there nope queen d8 the
queen bee Hades going for mate the rooks
gonna try to come in to d8 I don't know
what to go and say right now rook see -
where's your was the White King going
take me to there we shall analyze this
looks like a draw ever King King up rook
up so just check check check check check
you can't go to h3 goes Queen f5 check
rook see you for Brooks III check and
that leads to mate so it looks like KH 1
rook c1 check
wait but they're the contempt thing on
right they might try to avoid the draw -
you know they if they if they see an
immediate loss to be clear they won't
choose a loss over a draw that's not how
it just like if they don't see the
immediate loss they will do everything
they can to avoid the equal you couldn't
fool me any with that game earlier
that's the whole point is Houdini didn't
realize how bad c5 was which is why he
allowed it I'm just bitter it's fine no
you're bad I'm sorry I love I love your
love for high-quality chefs
so we're against 3 minutes 2 second
increment in these games which means
they're already just little awesome
and already so that game is a what about
the games where we're stock fish is
white we haven't been to those in a
while in the well which one you want to
look at diamonds okay the one that looks
like it's just simplifying into an equal
ending with an IQ P let's leave that
alone
let's go to the other one where which
100 White's just up a healthy pawn yeah
I didn't realize the ether bone was
actually tirage the sacrificing a pawn
allows white to be up I know it's just
exactly that's what it is it's the
tirage the tirage is played
look for white can get another W white
is I would say why it's completely
winning here
Bishop a2 is a funny moves that you take
Bishop e3 falls and then d4 falls yep
but I mean White has to be okay maybe
winning is strong but White has to be so
significantly better that white will win
this game so it's just that white
especially under time pressure you just
don't expect super actor
defense by the engines b5 it's calling
off the Sun he knew that stockfish
hadn't had got to play on pass on the
wild right grass is always greener
taking advantage of the desire whoa whoa
Houdini with white in that final game
there's this annoying pin on the a file
but what's the material account black of
some past pawns with his ePHI pawn has
made the whites attack on the King looks
like it could get nasty on the light
squares yeah what is going on here I
can't see a way for I mean black to get
out of checks I even if you witness
bishop see one like d6 yeah it seems
unlikely here black happily gives up the
night okay so I think Queens queen c5
queen see a queen f5 is just draw so
that looks he just got beat to know is
that how he wins the peace bet
yeah with a queen CA just draw my
perpetual check okay okay so Queen a5
Queen c8 yeah yeah a draw here with
perpetual check is is soon to happen
because white can't allow black to take
with the pole on and get a second Queen
yep and the other game was officially
drawn that weird bought vinick's I got
crazy that was just with white so it
means that the one decisive game here is
likely to be this one where what
stockfish was up a pawn now he's down a
piece dude no he's not down a piece no
it work ending what the world is going
on here it's all happening so fast
this is has to be a draw there's no way
that whoa actually have past ancient G
pawns
agent G pawns what f4 comes f4 comes so
I think black gonna take early that you
will yeah because you have to stop the C
pawn what King g3 works
rook c5 I guess is route d7 yeah wait
works e5 here yeah stock fish needs to
take the draw before his own contempt
gets him a loss but g6 now and then
she's six and there's mating no but g6
rook c8 I thought there's always gonna
be so how is black not winning now oh he
just takes the yeah I just check check
check
we're got seven with seven or it's my
gosh this is a headache
Wow
well it was probably winning honestly
I'm he had to be and probably was
winning for stockfish but this games
this game will come to the end courtesy
of some some pickle tickle let's move
back over to the bishop ending dead draw
dead draw so all draws stockfish will
maintain a full point lead heading into
bullet which one of these computers can
play bullet better than the other you're
gonna find out find out next time at
least we're not making you wait like a
week with like the speech Chess
Championship match right it's all
happening in one day Danny that was a
really exciting round and actually
stockfish looked to be ahead because it
stopped yeah pretty bad Vinick game with
black we thought white was ahead but
there must and then black we thought was
better but it was just a draw apparently
so I don't I didn't I couldn't keep
dragging my own thoughts so I don't know
but it you know and then stock fish was
the head with the white pieces and looks
fine with black so you know definitely a
good round for stock visions a shame
couldn't pull off any points because I
game in particular not this one but the
other draw was stock fish is white yeah
look pretty much winning yeah we could
try to back that thing up let's do it
because we got some time and we have our
own cloud analysis engine here what
where was the wind right I'm back on
move 65 where we have this we have well
we have e six on mu 69 in the two pawns
but with no time on the clock
they played played for some tickle like
I said but surprising so you think the
wind might have been earlier yeah the
one was definitely earlier when I was
camp ween Bishop and rug for his Queen
rook and Knight and you're clear on yeah
again it's not the easiest way there was
a straightforward missed win but you can
sustain that pressure build it up under
the duress of time limitations because
of the QuickTime bishal and clearly
White was unable to go for and win it
might be maybe move 59 maybe f5 was just
a little premature why should just sit
tight possible right yeah if I you know
if I looked so natural right the Queen
tonight protect the f5 square yep after
Knight g5 I mean still looks so good for
way
but I guess it's all whites whites
position became so open all the pawns
were traded well yeah what was h3 why
don't is G takes h4 if you're gonna like
do something weird yeah G is for good
yeah ugh poor does look good here and
then 94f takes g6 check and then take on
me for alright but I mean I don't know
if I don't know but with no time on the
clock obviously that's what we're seeing
the engines you know before you feel bad
for them remember they are computers
with no feelings secondly remember that
we put we put humans through these time
controls much more often right we get
Magnus Carlsen versus the car Nakamura
and the others that go down and the
speeches championship so yes blunders do
happen when when there's less time on
the clock apparently for both computers
and humans
speaking of which no time on the clock
well it hasn't started yet we are
getting set for the final round Robert
that is going to be bullet and it is
going to be fun based on what we saw
feels like we got a favorite stock fish
in the bullet to win this match yeah I
mean salvage hasn't playing better in
the last indefinite last round but
salvage is lucky or I should say
fortunate not lucky fortunate to be
ahead right now yep should be a time
match yeah but we'll see if if Houdini
can pull up something out of its bag of
magic tricks I love how you stopped
yourself from saying something else yep
I did that's okay well we'll keep those
imaginations to to the a file anyway
here we go so the games are starting no
way not starting hopefully to turn the
attention away from whatever we might
talk about but yeah all right the the
standings again or what we see in front
of us everybody of course to the left
you're reminded of what the final round
robin standings were after yesterday's
play if you missed it that was when we
still had all 10 computers going at it
but now it's down to one fish versus one
magician one opportunity one moment you
got to own it mom's sphaghetti all
stuff I was before you even went into
the mom's sphaghetti you just were
sounding like mmm
and I was impressed hey I knew you were
thinking that I'm always on the same
wavelength with you and I just busted
out when I was kind of worried that
you're gonna call me cheddar Bob well I
didn't want you know I get nervous but
on the surface I look calm and ready to
drop bombs oh boy oh boy you're really
doing it aren't you hey you know what
some of us listen to Eminem in our youth
and must mean both of us then yeah we
both did so you know back when uh back
when Marshall mattered opportunity only
comes once in a lifetime yes right here
we go
it's on stockfish versus Houdini the
final round stockfish is white with one
two one two Mic Check Houdini is white
with one two one minute plus two seconds
incremented Robert where would you like
to go Wow okay Bullock games galore and
I don't even know where to start this is
gonna be nuts
honestly we're just gonna have to do our
best and ask for forgiveness later
because Silas these games are just let's
go with stockfish games with white
because we've already seen a different
opening choice by a Houdini with black
yeah you know instead of this tirage
terribleness we see that early Bishop f5
which I used to play in my youth but is
sometimes seen as a bit questionable
because especially because they're the
Queen um b3 the pawn on b7 is now gonna
be under attack so something to keep in
mind for all your viewers is nice to
build your bishop but sometimes there
are pawns left behind and Danny does not
like that at all in others game you're
dealt in the other game where starfish
is white we have this kind of to rush
like structure at the pond c5 and we
will vary when we see an isolated pawn
but the good news for houdini's that is
not sacrifice a pawn in the interim so
it's not going to pawn down it's playing
with equal material and from there we
made the progress being made I guess we
should hop over to the Houdini with
white games
yes sir like I'm talking or any thousand
miles per minute we see in the first
game he
white has just taken a night on h6 which
collapses the black pawn structure
you're gonna have to take back on h6
with the Jeep on which means that the
Kings side is in shambles black did pick
up a pawn in the process on b2 can also
pick up this pawn on a - but what white
is doing is gonna castle use these open
files with rooks and challenged black
saying you're not gonna castle safely
because your King side is open and at
some point the rook can go to b3 then I
can move away from f3 and their work and
swing over to the King side as well so
right now black up to pawns but with the
inferior development and the worst pawn
structure so I think white has a
sufficient conversation but again we've
seen time and time again the extra
material has come to prove more than
enough despite the advantages in the
position so if you ever considered a
career as that guy that reads the the
verbiage at the end of a commercial
really fast
sorry because in the games go back to
where stock fish is white we see in the
first game this knight on b7 is not
looking too happy and nor is this
parlance seasick so Houdini has a lot of
weaknesses here that can be exploited
because right now there's a rook on c1
not only five putting pressure and look
at this Knight move ud6 the idea being
the knight is coming to c4 and trying to
totally close up clog the lane and
that's important because if white
captures on sea forever then black will
have to make a difficult choice stick
with the D pawn you'll allow the e3 pawn
potentially go to e4 stay with the
b-pawn then you know maybe Queen eight
for ideas instead white jumps in first
the c5 square and I think white is
better here after these trades because
the rook can never go to b8 look at that
Bishop on g3 covering that important
square which made black take with the
dependency for rather than the b-pawn so
but now events coming he'll yeah that
one looks good for white for sure and on
the other game where stockfish is white
we see that black is a very strange pawn
structure with pawns up double eight
pawns Bobby Fischer rolls over in his
grave yeah yeah at least once it's kind
of stop drop and roll in the grave of
this point because on fire alert but
there's a big problem for black look at
that these look at a five though yeah if
I does a good idea
because you needed to open something
look at that King coming into he
threatens f4 to get the King up
yeah but White has to be doing well here
because with the even material right a
week on look at the 9m d3 focus our
attention over on the other game where
stock fish is white the board on our
left another sacrifice by Houdini the
last time he did this he got a winning
attack I'm not sure it'll work this time
though but look at this he's he's down a
piece but he's got these two connected
passers on the Queen side and the
potential of rook g5 rook h5 Robert
hurry keep talking fast like that guy in
the commercial the big promise that at
some point Knight - before will be
painful for black in an endgame because
you're winning the pawns however for the
time being it looks like black is
picking up the White Queen the way it
has two rips in the night which is more
than enough usually but like you said
Dan is that pawn on b5 and c4 that it
looks to be put black ahead for example
Queen takes e4 now I don't see how white
will be doing much of anything but I
guess the front the real problem for
black is and why this being a repetition
then we take on e4 and night before
comes a6 is falling the white rooks
cover the second rank well with you the
past pawns are not going anywhere so
right now there's been a repetition on
now Queen takes e4 so night before is
not possibly be one check which means
that the King s go back to h2 and now
the repetition ensues so we'll see they
may they may still Trey yeah he's now
going for the repetition black wants the
whole thing Bob Barker I don't want a
piece I want the whole thing look at
black is on the attack with the C pawn
though you know speaking of being on the
attack with a pass with a passed pawn
look at the game where Houdini is white
against stockfish there is a pawn on a -
so yes blacks King looks quite
vulnerable but at the same time there's
a move away from promotion with that
upon the seventh rank so there are some
checks here for white I don't see
actually how me black king is getting
out of it I guess Queen e7 Queen g7 has
just played you know it's too little too
late for white the King looks weak
but that passed pawn is very very strong
so it looks like there's gonna that one
with black we have an official draw in
one of the games with stockfish being
white against Houdini and the other game
are Houdini is white Houdini is
temporarily down a queen but is about to
promote and who's king is worse I guess
black is getting out of this
even material the 94 now picks up the c3
pawn but in these end games you have to
be very careful where okay well now that
is gonna be a draw now simplifying that
was smart waiting for the Knights
because now it's an easy draw so yep
that game over and done with so that
leaves us with two games and somehow
what should we call it Houdini survived
with the white pieces despite that pawn
in the seventh for now I'm looking at
this game and Houdini is doing just fine
he defended everything yeah except that
pawn isn't still gonna be a huge news
there's ninety four oh he gets away with
it because of the discovered attack on
the rook yeah these guys that the
computer tactics that occur here and go
to the first game or Houdini is black
Houdini is up a queen and not completely
won on that one
what yo you led the attack we hadn't we
missed going to the other games but all
of a sudden tides have turned and black
cuz I'll be a queen just for one night
completely winning how did stock fish
blow that game we're gonna have to back
up and take a look everybody what about
the other game where Houdini is black
against stalkers I guess that was
already a draw that game was drawn and
we have one more game or Houdini has
white we're stock fishes up a full piece
so the only issue remaining is that the
black has an H pawn right his pawn each
sit but it's not an issue here that was
kind of a trick look at the H 1 square
the square promotion matches the bishop
on the light square so even if the rooks
are traded it still will be a win that
is problematic for Houdini so Houdini be
getting a win with black but
unfortunately drew the other game with
white and is about to lose this one so
that means that stop fish will win by a
game and it's a fluke in my opinion I'm
still bitter about it that one game that
decides the whole match is the contempt
game that's what that's what it's called
there's you know deflategate there's a
flake eight this is contempt gate oh did
the contempt gate and so the last game
remaining is this one where black is up
a rook Bishop and H phonic and just
Queen and it will be checkmate so first
of all can we all give Robert a golfclap
I mean he deserves more than just a
jingle design for him let's listen to it
again
[Music]
Thank You Bobbi yes
but seriously that was some amazing
talking and commentary
we now have checkmate on both boards we
can see on the analysis board that black
did checkmate with the Brooke and on the
on the main board stock of a stock fish
was made it himself but you're right it
all comes down to that one game that
stock fish won because of Houdini's I
don't even I don't know what it is I
don't know what it is right it's it's
how do we describe what what what that
is it is frustrating uninspiring huh you
know it's it's kind of like what Fizbo
did to me in the last day but you know
I'm more seriously I was amazed by
Houdini's resourcefulness with the black
pieces right these sacrifices that led
not even telling me to check me but it
really shifted the transform the way the
game was unfolding and so Houdini one of
the nicer games in my opinion you know
even disregarding the fact that big mess
should have been even if not for that
contempt game Houdini had want some
really nice games with black and you
know if we can look at this last round
game because since the match is over and
we have to have him graduate I'm going
through I know but you know if we look
through this game we saw that black was
worse right no question this knight on
b7 was really awkward a movie you on
hold on him you know we go to move let's
say let's sort of move 20 and and
they're talking about the game with the
yes so black is worse the Knights on b7
okay yeah go ahead right we we just see
how okay the knight came in to see for
that was obviously really smart at some
point but we had mentioned that look
this eep-eep on he should give white an
advantage but as soon as this Knight
went to a2 which I mean this kind of is
a move that keeps t4 protected and maybe
is eventually trying to f3 e4 something
like that night a to Bishop takes h3
sacrifice that's one of those things
that actually humans miss all the time
we say wow our position is so good let
me consolidate let me
reroute my pieces to the best squares
and we overlook these sacrifices in as
soon as this happened yes there was no
immediate checkmate
but the rook came to e6 swung in to give
a check the Queen went to g5 where you
know there's no immediate checkmate once
more but there are some problems with
this pawn III it looks to me that white
should be doing all right but I thought
I do it but but the ideal t4 is a super
nice shot oh absolutely and what's nice
is that the Queen g5 data is a simple
Queen f5 and then rookie 4 was just
beautiful saying I'm gonna go room g5
and when you're Queen and so it's I
think the engines probably I didn't have
an engine in fronting probably evaluate
something equal because of all the
checks that leads me to it's not
equality but I don't see why it's equal
if anything black will always have these
resourceful Queen h4 queen g4 or queen
around the board it's around the world
with the Queen yo c3 perfect sense right
why just agree to a draw when we can
push forward and now night before queen
g4 check you know something tells me
that maybe it's not actually winning for
black but you know again without the
time to really get into the depth
necessary to save a game like this black
is the one that's ahead so it's a really
nice showing there by Houdini I was very
impressed and surprised I love the
technique when he starts pushing the H
pawn to right it's very very instructive
principle of two weaknesses where you've
got the C pawn and but it's been
blockaded you're like okay well you've
stopped the C pawn well now now try to
stop the C and the H pawn right and
that's a very instructive moment for any
human being to understand that often you
can blow your advantage if you become
obsessed with just one side of the board
or one way to win but Houdini very very
smartly has patience shows that the
blockade is not going to be able to be
held as soon as there are two past pawns
in the mix and I think that was kind of
the beginning of the end right once the
age font came in eventually it was just
the blockade breaks down and Houdini
broke through so yeah I think you framed
that perfectly that when you have an
advantage on one side of the board
sometimes one advantage is not enough
and you need to create not just a
distraction but create a strategy on the
other side of the board that takes the
attention away of the white rooks and
the King such that it's hard to defend
both the C pawn that's passed and the H
punt and I believe that the engines miss
evaluate positions like this all the
time now that's not to say that I'm
smarter than the engine of course not
but I think they often think a position
is just equal and often you know the lie
saying that you know it should shouldn't
be too worried some and then all of a
sudden you let it sit you let the engine
sit for a while and then the tide starts
to turn the engines wheels start to show
that as time goes on well you know I
don't like this position as much
objectively black is better so I think
that's what happened here and Houdini
did very well to gather the full point
and dd-did black also won this round and
bullet with stockfish doing just that if
we back up and take a quick look at it I
think the critical moment and this one
well Houdini defended really well
despite black having this extended pawn
on a2 but as we got into the endgame
where was the blunder after 94 Knight c3
Brooksie for black eventually won the
knight on c3 due to the MIS placement of
the rook on f3 because if the knight
moved everyone there would have been
ideas like Bishop to d5 pinning the rook
on f3 to the King on g2 so that's kind
of where stockfish took it down right
there
as soon as you saw this move rook to a3
and on that note Robert that means our
final standings and everything really
came down to the game from a couple
rounds ago if it's still in the in the I
believe it is no this isn't it I'm
looking for the game from a couple
rounds ago because we got a highlight
our controversial breakthrough gate
contempt gate one more time
that being excuse me we got to get it I
got to get it up I got to show it one
more time I'm trying to breathe I'm try
to take it easy not only am I out of
breath from just talking as fast I've
ever spoken in my life but that this
game that you're about to show just
hurts me in the chest right in the heart
air it does it does it hurts it hurts me
that you're hurt I'm trying to find it
there it has ended with a couple of
Queens and a whole bucket of fun Robert
so everybody if you're just joining us
it is official stockfish the final
standings let me show them to you you're
on the edge of your seat stockfish has
won the chess comm the first ever chess
calm computer Chess Championship ignore
the scores on the left in
that image that was at the end of day
three the live match standings there he
won by a score a ten and a half to nine
and a half but in the end yes both
engines had decisive results against the
other and yes there were interesting and
sort of unique computer ish moments that
happened but overall the one really
thing that stuck out was that we had
this game here and I'll really stop it
once it starts right here I moved 37
because officially or closed down
there's very limited ways to break
through besides this one point of action
potentially on b6 we actually found the
idea and recommended that black just put
a rook there and the truth is white has
nothing to gain because once there's a
piece on b6 white doesn't even want to
capture it with the bishop because
there's there's no files to be open to
you there's no progress to be to be had
yes this game goes on for a really
really long time but we're gonna get to
some interesting points here in about
two seconds so so once that progress was
was made stockfish made his final
attempt to create a new way to break
through by taking on d4 naturally black
takes back with the C pawn because
taking with the e pawn might leave a
more dangerous breakthrough of 'if I've
eventually against the black King but as
long as black fills that Square which
you Dini does for the first time on move
81 with rook to c5 take a look at this
position everybody right what did you
call it Robert it's checkers it's
checkers not yes it's just over this is
a draw but again part of the format we
have here is not only designed to create
the most aggressive style chess but
potentially prevent them from just
deciding that everything's equal and
ending the game to be fair to the format
okay
the computers are not programmed to go
for a loss we did see many draws we see
more draws than decisive results it does
happen however if they don't see the
exact consequences of avoiding the draw
yes they are designed to avoid to have
contempt for the peaceful result we want
them to be aggressive and so in this
game Houdini eventually either just
doesn't understand that the c5 break is
is actually going to give white
something or we'll do whatever it takes
to avoid the 50 move draw and when we
got to move I think it was 116
yep right around here is when we saw
Houdini make that kind of abandoned yes
the brook was on c5 one more time and
once we got here to move 116 we see that
rook to leave the c5 square and that's
the last chance Houdini ever has to stop
the breakthrough with eventually
stockfish also in contempt of a draw
says well now it's been 50 moves guess
what I have to make a pawn move in
Robert there's only one legal pawn move
on this board and that's c5 I find the
whole thing just so ironic and weird
that c5 is played basically in a
forceful way only because they have to
so they finally make this move and c5
actually ends up being the breakthrough
that stockfish needs to open up the C
file and go on to win this game but as
we said if coud Houdini just sits the
rook on c5 it's a draw anyway so there's
my summary gave you a little bit of a
break there brother to talk a little bit
you did such a great job on the bullet
that was the controversial we'll call it
contempt gate that Robert is so up in
arms about either way in the end this
game ends up being the one the people
are really gonna remember from this
match as why stockfish is the chess comm
computer chess champion Robert your
final thoughts well you did a great job
of summing that up and I think that you
know there is a huge instruction point
in that game is that when there's only
one break in the position you always
have to consider it in every single move
from both sides but to some of the
entire event while the the round robin
stage was really fun for us you know two
games but in each individual match or
two games on the white and one black we
we're introduced to some fun engines
that I had never seen before we saw a
gull get the stuffing beaten out of it
we saw Fizbo provide entertainment day
after day and most importantly we saw
some amazing chess by these engines of
course they're stronger than the best
humans you know even Magnus Carlsen
doesn't stand a chance against the the
best has no insult to any human player
just that's where we are with engines
and machine learning but we did see
stock fish prevail it was a
controversial way to that finish but you
have to commend stock wishes programmers
and you know the kind of open source
technology for really providing some
great entertainment and some great value
to the chess community
and I think it'll be interesting to see
I mean this is surely not gonna be the
last time we host this event now we know
what happens when the gloves come off
like I said the time controls get faster
just like they do in our speeches
championship and and and and we saw a
mess of things and some really weird and
fun and unique moments that only
computers can deliver us so as much as I
think you and I both I mean the honest
truth is we'll just air it all out
Robert and I were not really that
excited about this event initially
because watching computers play each
other wasn't our favorite thing to do
it's not as fun as Magnus being on
webcam stuffing his face with Cheetos
sorry that's the truth but I feel like
as this went on I was I was really I had
a lot of fun I was I was intrigued by
the different way that the engines
arrived at results that even if humans
kind of assess and learn the same or
come to the same conclusions the the
method the journey is so different and
you know at some point we we had
machines learning from humans in chess
and now we have humans learning from
machines right Robert that the scales
have tipped and the developers that have
created these engines are now are now
you constantly in awe of what these
engines come up with so on that note
we're gonna leave we're gonna leave it
and show the actually will show Fizbo
one more time they're the the finals the
final standings as I as I bring up the
our final standings image here Fizbo
Robert you want to say anything to fizz
about one more time before we let the
let the clown off the hook I'm gonna
have to you know go and put Modern
Family on episodes 9 season 1 I believe
that's the episode of Fizbo but I think
there's a lot to be excited about not
just because these engines with Danny
I mean Wesley so and magnus carlsen
playing he's having that's right
two days now that's right well there you
go we're gonna leave it right here with
the standings again you can see it
stockfish one that's all she wrote
Robert thanks for flying alongside me
fans thanks for being here really
appreciate all of your support please
consider giving us a sub here at twitch
TV slash chess please consider going to
chess comm signing up and seeing if you
can play like chess engines Robert I
will have the call with Magnus Carlsen
on Saturday versus Wesley so you and I
will be together this coming Tuesday
one of those players Magnus or Wesley
will be playing Sascha Grichuk so I
don't have a speeches championship
graphic ready but if you're wondering
where you're gonna be at your when
you're gonna get your next fill of
awesome chess action everybody it's
right here in just about 48 hours as
Magnus Carlsen plays Wesley so Robert
love you buddy and I'll talk to you
later
sounds good Danny